Wer immer auf Draht sein will, hat sich des Kupferkabels längst entledigt. Das Handy ist zur Standardausstattung des mobilen Computerfreaks geworden. Als universelles Kommunikationsgerät ist das Funkbrikett unschlagbar und gewinnt auch für die Internetnutzung immer weiter an Bedeutung. Mit den Funknetzen beschleunigt sich die Entwicklung. Neue Dienste halten Einzug in immer komplexere Geräte, die selbst schon vollwertige Computer geworden sind. Neben den bekannten halten die Kommunikationsklötzchen auch allerlei unbekannte Funktionen parat und viele neue Begriffe und Codes verwirren den Benutzer. Der Laie staunt und der Hacker kriegt feuchte Hände. Chaosradio beleuchtet die Technik jenseits der Knöpfe. Wie die Netze funktionieren, warum sie manchmal nicht so gut funktionieren und was Handys so alles Interessantes ausspucken, wenn man sie nur richtig darum bittet.
Wir sollten immer Live-DJs haben, das bringt es total. Dazu gleich aber mehr, erstmal der berühmt berüchtigte Mikrofoncheck.
Ja, das Mikrofon funktioniert ganz gut.
Wenn du das wussten hörst, mein herzlich willkommen im Chaosradio, der Blue Moon bei Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, der sich mit Computern und allem, was damit zusammenhängt, beschäftigt. Heute das Thema GSM oder auch Handys, Deutschland ist eigentlich das einzige Land, in dem man Handys sagt, oder?
Also zumindest die deutschsprachige Region.
Was sagt man in anderen Ländern? Am ich sagen, Cellular, was einfach scheiße zu sprechen ist?
Setze ich hier nie durch?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, nee.
Das klingt auch irgendwie blöd.
Und es wird natürlich heute auch um das gehen, was am Wochenende die gesamte Weltpresse, naja, nicht ganz, aber zumindest die deutsche Presse, doch sehr beschäftigt hat. Und in diversen Schlagzeilen, Schlagzeilen am Sonntag zu lesen mal, der inzwischen doch, ja, der sich inzwischen rumgesprochene GSM-Hack. Dazu am Anfang dieser Sendung vieles. Und wir können ja mal kurz sagen, wer alles da ist heute in dieser Ausgabe vom Chaosradio.
Tim ist mit am Start.
Und Tobias.
Und wer introduced die DJs? Ihr könnt nachher hier anrufen in der Sendung. Ihr könnt euch natürlich auch per Chat dazuschalten, sobald ich dann mit meinem Rechner hier wieder irgendwie den Fritz Server finde, den ich moment nicht finde.
Oh ja, DNS-Probleme gibt's heute noch und nöcher.
Vielleicht was wir noch nicht wissen.
Wir haben hier drüben auch kein Netz.
Ah klar, wir hängen ja am selben, oder?
Naja, wir haben vielleicht die falsche App hier, also wir kriegen das raus.
Aber wenn wir wieder ein Netz haben, dann gibt's zwei Chats heute. Nämlich einmal den sozusagen normalen Fritz-Chat und dann noch einen Telnet-Chat von euch richtig.
Ja, genau. Das ist der Chaos Classic Chat, den wir hier auf unserem, auf www.ccc.de eingerichtet haben. Da kann man nicht mit einem Webbrowser drauf, ist da denn der Webbrowser kann auch selber Telnet, also nehmt euch irgendwie ein Telnet-Software, einfach Standard-Telnet auf www.ccc.de. Da sind dann auch noch ein paar Jungs von uns und geben gerne Hintergrundinformationen, falls irgendwelche Fragen auftauchen, die wir hier nicht beantworten können.
Ansonsten, falls ihr einfach nur im Web chatten wollt, könnt ihr das dann irgendwann tun unter www.fritz.de slash speakers. Ähm, moment geht's wie gesagt nicht. Looking up host www.fritz.de. Sind das nicht genau die Sachen, die wir lieben am Internet?
Toll. Ja, wir stöpseln hier noch ein paar Kabel. Wir wollen das ja heute hier mal warm machen mit dem Internet in dem Studio.
Das kriegen wir noch hin.
Haben wir vielleicht sein Kabel schon rausgezogen?
Wir haben es wieder reingesteckt und die Linklappe leuchtet.
Das soll man doch nicht machen, wenn der Rechner an ist.
Ich versuch dich jetzt erstmal einzupähen.
Okay, lass erst mal ein bisschen hören und dann gibt es gleich eine Einführung zum Thema. Der D2 Mann ist Mann, Haig. Das Schöne an so Meldungen wie Handys gehackt oder Sicherheitsloch in D2-Karten oder so ein Kram ist ja immer, dass eigentlich niemand genau weiß, worum es eigentlich geht, aber alle Leute plötzlich Panik kriegen. Und ihr habt heute im Fritz-Programm schon einiges zu diesem Thema gehört und werdet jetzt ganz ausführlich und ganz genau informiert von den Leuten, die es am besten wissen müssen vom Chaos Computer Club, nämlich.
Wir richten uns jetzt auch ein bisschen ein und gucken gerade ein bisschen bedroppelt, weil wir hier noch irgendwie kein Internetanstalt kriegen. Aber ich glaube, das Projekt müssen wir erstmal ein bisschen zurückstellen. Ansonsten haben wir uns hoffentlich ganz gut vorbereitet auf die ganze Geschichte. Dieser Hack hat uns ja ganz schön in Betrieb gehalten in den letzten Tagen. War irgendwie ein halber Rummel.
Mich hat neulich jemand gefragt, der wusste, dass es diese Sendung gibt und so. Der hat gesagt, verdienen die damit eigentlich Geld? Ich hab gesagt, nee, nicht direkt, weil dafür gibt es ja kein Geld. Wer sollte einen dafür bezahlen für solche Geschichten? Was bringt das eigentlich dem Club als solches?
Na, das ist unser Auftrag.
Naja, ich geb nur die Frage einfach so weiter.
Ja, wir sind ja im Namen des Herrn unterwegs. Und haben ja sozusagen, dass das in unseren Statuten, in unseren Vereinssatzungen sozusagen als zieldefiniertes Daumen geht. Die gesellschaftliche Problematik, die mit dem Einsatz von Technologien, von modernen Technologien hier verbunden ist, die, soweit es eben möglich ist, Transparenz zu machen. Das ist genau das, was du eben gesagt hast. So dieses, das ist so ein super technisches Ding, so ein unglaubliche Detailfiller. Wessen Handy macht denn hier Müll?
Meins, ich hab's ausgemacht.
Und so schwierige Sachverhalte rüberzubringen, das schlägt halt sehr oft fehl, weil es einfach nicht wirklich einfach möglich ist, den Leuten klarzumachen, was die tatsächlichen Auswirkungen sind von bestimmten Maßnahmen. Sagen wir mal hier zum Beispiel diese geplante Gen-Datenbank und so. Da werden halt immer irgendwelche Sachen nach vorne geschoben und die Befürworter kommen halt mit, wir müssen die Verbrecher hinter Schloss und Riegel bringen, wo dann irgendwie bei der Angst der Leute, die so herrscht, immer schwierig dagegen zu argumentieren ist. Und wir versuchen halt eine andere Variante zu beleuchten. Und manchmal fällt es eben uns leichter, unsere Position klarzumachen, jetzt zum Beispiel eben mit diesem Hack, der halt den Leuten sozusagen direkt an Geldbeutel geht, wo eben auch ganz klar eine Aussage widerlegt worden konnte wieder einmal, die halt so im Raum steht, nämlich dass das, wie das immer so schön heißt, alles ganz sicher ist und man muss sich ja gar keine Gedanken machen. Und sicherlich gibt es in diesen GSM-Netzen, um es gleich mal vorweg zu sagen, eine ganze Menge Sicherheit in Einführungsstrichen. Also da ist schon an vielen Stellen für bestimmte Dinge gesorgt worden, aber der Teufel liegt halt im Detail. Und gerade diese Sache kann ich jetzt sozusagen bedrohen werden. Das ist ja ein ganz wesentlicher Punkt. Schon damals, wenn man sein Telefon zu Hause gehabt hat, war es meistens relativ problemlos möglich. Man marschiert halt irgendwie in den Keller, klemmt sich parallel zu irgendeiner Leitung ran und dann konnte man eben auch irgendwie auf Kosten eines anderen telefonieren. Nun musste man eben dazu ein Kabel legen, irgendwie in das Haus und da vor Ort nachvollziehbar irgendwie mechanisch eingreifen. Und im Zuge der Virtualisierung des Ganzen mit diesen Handys ist man halt nicht mehr so sehr an den Ort gebunden. Und da ist es natürlich ein sehr viel größeres Problem. Kann jetzt jemand auf meine Kosten telefonieren? Das beschäftigt die Leute natürlich. Und das haben wir jetzt gerade mal wieder zeigen können. Deswegen war halt auch die Resonanz so hoch.
Bevor man jetzt genau erklärt, was da eigentlich passiert ist oder beziehungsweise was da exemplarisch probiert worden ist und auch gemacht worden ist. Die allererste Frage, die sich auftut, warum D2? Sind diese Karten so unterschiedlich? D1, E+, sind das so unterschiedliche Verfahren?
Na ja, also eigentlich ist alles D1, D2, E+, GSM und nach dem GSM Standard implementiert. Das heißt, es gibt da nicht viele Möglichkeiten, was anders zu machen. Außer eben in diesem speziellen Bereich der Sicherheit, der von diesem Hack betroffen ist. Da ist es so, dass vom GSM-Komitee ähnlich ein Vorschlag unterbreitet wurde. Und viele sind halt dem Vorschlag gefolgt, unter anderem D2. Und andere Netze haben den Vorschlag abgewandelt, beziehungsweise was Eigenes an der Stelle benutzt. Und das ist zum Beispiel bei D1 und E+.
Ähm, Moment, das hab ich jetzt nicht ganz verstanden. D2 ist den Vorschlägen gefolgt, und deswegen ist da eine Sicherheitslücke?
Na ja, ob die anderen eine Sicherheitslücke haben, das kann man momentan noch nicht sagen, weil die Algorithmen nicht offengelegt sind. Es ist halt so, dass die entsprechenden Algorithmen, die für die Sicherheit sorgen, von diesem Standardkomitee entworfen wurden, die wurden aber nicht veröffentlicht. Die bekam man bloß als Hersteller bzw. als Betreiber eines solchen Netzes. Und dadurch hat es halt so lange gedauert, bis offensichtlich wurde, dass da ein Problem existiert. Also dieser Algorithmus wurde lange Zeit geheim gehalten und wurde dann aus Dokumenten, die irgendwo aufgetaucht sind und ein bisschen Reverse Engineering von der Smartcard Developers Association komplett dokumentiert. Und daraufhin haben die das, was sie herausgefunden haben, an zwei Forscher in Berkeley geschickt, wie sie das angeguckt haben und festgestellt haben, da gibt es eine Schwachstelle.
Also wir waren nicht sozusagen hinter D2 her oder so.
Genau, da aufzähl die Frage.
Darum ging es halt zunächst einmal nicht, sondern das Resultat war halt nur, dass diese Schwachstelle, die dort dokumentiert wurde, also um die Geschichte nochmal kurz transparent zu machen, also auch in den USA gibt es mittlerweile viele GSM-Netze und natürlich sind auch da viele Leute dabei, sich mit der Technologie auseinanderzusetzen, gerade weil es in den USA auch noch was wirklich Neues ist. Und im GSM ist viel standardisiert. Da gibt es dicke, fette Bücher, die man kaufen und wälzen kann, wo drin steht, dass es so bis ins letzte Detail. Nur an der Stelle, wo es eben um diesen kritischen Sicherheitsaspekt geht, also die Authentifizierung des Kunden, wie das so schön heißt, also die Sicherstellung, dass derjenige, der da behauptet, dass er es sei, es auch wirklich ist, dass es nicht die Möglichkeit gibt, für jemand anderen dasselbe zu behaupten. Diese Protokolle oder ein Teil dieser Protokolle, also der Kern, der wichtige Punkt, der war halt nicht dokumentiert. Zunächst einmal basierte sozusagen die Sicherheit nur darauf, dass es eben keiner wusste oder zumindest keiner, das ist ja auch nicht richtig, weil da gibt es irgendwie tausende von Leuten weltweit, die natürlich bei den Firmen arbeiten und selbstverständlich diese Protokolle kennen, aber eben Verschwiegenheitsverpflichtungen unterlegen und so weiter. Aber wie das nun mal so ist, irgendwann hat sich halt einer mal ein Herz genommen und hat das Dokument, das Fragliche, veröffentlicht, in diesem Fall auf dem Netz, ne?
Ja ne, das ist nicht auf dem Netz veröffentlicht worden, sondern das ist Leuten zugespielt worden. Die Geschichte, die ich gehört habe, ist, dass es einer Universität zu Forschungszwecken zur Verfügung gestellt wurde und die Universität wurde nicht zu Stillschweigen verpflichtet. Das heißt, sie mussten kein Non-Disclosure Agreement unterschreiben. Und haben dann deshalb auch den Algorithmus, also diese Papiere weitergeben können, die waren nicht vollständig. Die Smartcard Developers Association, ein Zusammenschluss von Privatleuten in kleineren Firmen weltweit, die hat sich dann halt hingesetzt und anhand von tatsächlich existierenden Chips herausgefunden, wie es denn nun genau ist. Und erst als diese Arbeit getan war, wurde der komplette Algorithmus auch im Netz veröffentlicht.
Okay, wir machen gleich nochmal richtig von Anfang an, was ist passiert, wo sind da überhaupt Sicherheitslücken, für wen ist das eine tatsächliche Gefahr, warum setzen sich Leute überhaupt damit auseinander. Jetzt machen wir gleich alles nochmal nach dem Fritz Kurz Info und hören bis dahin noch ein bisschen Simplicity of Sounds. Schöne, relaxte Klänge. Bisher von Simplicity of Sound. Mal sehen, was wir da noch hören.
Bis 1 Uhr.
Aber sehen wir wahrscheinlich weniger. Sondern hören werden muss.
22.30 Uhr übrigens. Beschluss, die Balkan-Kontaktgruppe hat sich am Abend in Rom auf neue Sanktionen gegen Jugoslawien verständigt. So sollen Guthaben im Ausland sofort eingefroren werden. Jugoslawien wird vorgeworfen, einen Dialog mit den Albanern in der serbischen Unruhe-Provinz Kosovo zu verweigern. Klimaschutz. Deutschland und die anderen 14 EU-Staaten haben heute das UNO-Protokoll von Kyoto unterzeichnet. Darin verpflichten sich die Industrienationen, den Ausstoß von Treibhausgasen bis zum Jahr 2012 auf das Niveau von 1990 zu senken. Lehrstellenstreit. Das Bundeskabinett hat den Berufsbildungsbericht 98 verabschiedet. Minister Rutgers geht davon aus, dass jedem ausbildungswilligen Jugendlichen eine Lehrstelle angeboten werden kann. Die SPD warf ihm Beschönigung vor. Eingeständnis. Der Verfassungsschutz hat Defizite bei der Bekämpfung des Rechtsextremismus in Ostdeutschland eingeräumt. In Brandenburg und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern bestehe für Ausländer eine deutlich höhere Gefährdung durch rechte Gewalt als in den alten Ländern. Abtasten. Drei Tage nach der Landtagswahl gab es heute in Sachsen-Anhalt erste Gespräche über eine neue Landesregierung. Spitzenpolitiker der SPD trafen sich nacheinander mit Vertretern von CDU und PDS. Fußball. Die Ergebnisse der Bundesliga. Hertha BSC verlor bei Bochum 1 zu 2. Bielefeld und Kaiserslautern trennten sich 2 zu 2. Und das gleiche Ergebnis gab es auch zwischen Leverkusen und Dortmund und Schalke gewann gegen Köln 1 zu 0. In der kommenden Nacht einzelne Schauer, örtlich Nebel, 12 bis 8 Grad. Kirstin, weil sie liegen uns nicht vor, jetzt wünscht alles Mögliche.
Prost. Ich find das so, du klingst so schön relaxed, wenn du das Info machst.
Ja sonst nicht?
Mal und einmal mit dem Kurzinfo.
Ich heiße BWL-Studentin, bin Margit im 17.
Semester. Aber wer ist eigentlich dieser Fontane?
Fontane 98. Auf den Spuren Fontane.
Von Fontane. Fontane 98.
Am 1. Mai in Ritz Extra. Am 2. Mai in Wollmann.
Mit Wosch durch die Ost- und Westmark.
Und wir werden noch ungefähr eine halbe Stunde haben, ohne eure Anrufe. Danach sind die Leitungen dann frei hier. Weil erstmal wollen wir euch in Ruhe erklären, was eigentlich genau passiert ist beim Thema D2. Ich persönlich bei solchen Geschichten immer so ultra schwierig finde, dass ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen kann, wie man überhaupt anfängt. Also ich hab jetzt ein Handy in der Hand, ich hab mein Computer da stehen und da ist eine Karte drin. Ich überlege ja nicht als erstes, ob man die kopieren kann, sondern erstmal überlege ich ja wahrscheinlich, komme ich da irgendwie ran an die Daten, die da drauf sind oder was sind da überhaupt für Daten drauf? Ich hab kurz auf den Chaos Radio Seiten ein bisschen mir das angeguckt, Chaosradio ccc.de übrigens. Und da sieht aber noch eine Menge Verkabelung und eine Menge Bauteilen aus, bei denen ich nicht mal weiß, wie man die richtig beschreibt.
Es ist so schwierig vom Setup. Man muss natürlich wissen, was man braucht.
Und dass man will erstmal, oder?
Na ja, das war eigentlich schon ziemlich klar. Als wir diese Informationen bekommen haben, also diesen fehlenden Algorithmus, ging es ja um diese Sache mit der Authentifizierung. Der Kunde macht gegenüber seinem Netz klar, wer er ist. Na ja, das war halt eine interessante Information. Es war ja nicht nur dieses Protokoll beschrieben. Also es war ja nicht nur jetzt etwas bekannt, was vorher sozusagen unbekannt gelassen worden ist, sondern die eigentliche Hitmeldung dazu war, dass eine andere Gruppe von Leuten, das waren diese Isaac, die Isaac-Leute Berkeley, die haben sich diesen Algorithmus dann angeschaut und haben festgestellt, dass er eine mathematische Schwäche aufwies. Weil zunächst einmal ist ja auch so ein Sicherheitsalgorithmus ein Sicherheitsalgorithmus, der nicht so ohne Weiteres zu knacken ist.
Ich unterbreche dich noch mal ganz kurz, weil wir reden schon von Protokollen, Algorithmen und so weiter und so fort. Also prinzipiell geht es erstmal darum, wenn du sagst, der Benutzer identifiziert sich im Netz als solcher, das tut er mit dieser Karte. Also in dem Moment, wo ich mit meiner Karte telefoniere, weiß das Netz, das bin ich sozusagen.
Genau, also das werden wir noch mal kurz das Szenario aufzeigen, was da eigentlich ist. Wir haben das Netz, wir haben das Telefon und in dem Telefon haben wir diese SIM-Karte, die Kundenkarte. Das sind die drei Komponenten. Und in der SIM-Karte, nicht im Handy, sondern in der SIM-Karte, steckt die Intelligenz, dass es sich dabei eben um deine Rufnummer handelt. Dass dieses Telefon jetzt für deine Telefonnummer Rufe annimmt und wenn du wegtelefonierst, dann geht das auf deine Karte.
Deshalb kannst du dir auch einfach ein neues Telefon kaufen, ohne eine neue Nummer zu kriegen. Einfach die Karte in das andere Telefon tun und dann funktioniert das.
Und jetzt ist halt die Frage, die sich dann stellt, kann jemand anderes so tun, als ob er meine Karte hätte?
Genau, darum geht's.
Dazu sollten wir vielleicht erstmal beleuchten, was eigentlich das Netz tut, um rauszukriegen, wer ich bin. Ich hab also jetzt ein Telefon.
Ja, und das funktioniert dann so, dass das Handy erst mal sagt, ja, ich habe die und die Seriennummer. Also die Karte sagt das dem Handy und das Handy sagt das dem Netz. Und daraufhin schickt das Netz eine bestimmte Zufallszahl an das Handy. Die hat sich das Netz ausgedacht. Zufallszahl?
Also keine bestimmte Zufallszahl, sondern eine Zufallszahl.
Eine zufällig gewählte Zahl, die eindeutig ist. Und nicht vorher verwendet wurde und sicher von der entsprechenden Hardware usw. Diese Zufallszahl geht jetzt in die SIM-Karte rein. Und wird dort mit einem bestimmten Algorithmus verrechnet. Und mit einem bestimmten Schlüssel für diesen Algorithmus. Und daraus wird eine Antwort generiert. Und diese Antwort wird zurück ans Netz geschickt. Und das Netz macht intern genau dieselbe Berechnung. Das heißt, es nimmt diese Zufallszahl, kennt auch den Schlüssel und den Algorithmus und berechnet die Antwort und vergleicht jetzt die Antwort, die es selber berechnet hat, mit dem, was meine Chipkarte zurückgeschickt hat. Und wenn die Antworten gleich sind, dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass die Chipkarte echt ist und dann akzeptiert das Handy die Karte.
Und das alles innerhalb von Bruchteilen von Sekunden.
Also zwei Sachen, die sind vielleicht noch erwähnenswert. Der Aufwand wird halt deshalb getrieben, damit dieser Schlüssel nicht selber über das Netz geschickt werden muss. Sondern man führt an zwei Stellen die gleiche Berechnung auf Basis einer Zufallszahl durch. Und wenn das Ergebnis dasselbe ist, und das Ergebnis kann man problemlos übertragen, ohne irgendwas zu verraten, dann geht man davon aus, dass es richtig ist, was diese SIM-Karte behauptet.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn ich irgendwie diese zweite Stelle kreieren kann, die aufs selbe Ergebnis kommt, habe ich eine SIM-Karte simuliert.
Man braucht also Kenntnis des genauen Algorithmuses und man braucht den Schlüssel, der für diesen Algorithmus verwendet wird. In jeder Chipkarte steckt ein anderer Schlüssel drin und im Netz ist auch zu jeder Karte der entsprechende Schlüssel gespeichert und der hat Einfluss auf die Berechnung. Wenn man die nicht kennt, kann man die Berechnung nicht durchführen. Das Ziel ist also aus dieser Chipkarte, den Schlüssel heraus zu bekommen. Dann kann ich eine Karte nachbauen.
Das war sozusagen der Auftrag.
Und wer hat damit angefangen und wie hat es dann geschafft?
Ich hoffe, ihr habt es schon gesehen. Ich hoffe, ihr habt es schon gesehen. Ich hoffe, ihr habt es schon gesehen. Also wir haben uns das natürlich alles vor einer Weile schon mal angeguckt und sind aufgrund der öffentlich verfügbaren Informationen soweit gekommen, zu sehen, wie das prinzipiell funktioniert. Was wir halt nicht wussten, ist, wie dieser Algorithmus funktioniert, der in der Chipkarte läuft. Der wird in Standards A3 bzw.
A8 genannt.
Es ist ein und derselbe Berechnungsschritt. Der zweite Schritt, der A8 Schritt, dient dazu, den Schlüssel für die Sprachverschlüsselung festzulegen. Aber dazu kommen wir vielleicht später nochmal. Wir reden erst mal über den A3 Teil. Die genaue Implementation stand nicht im Standard. Die genaue Implementation wurde durch dieses Dokument, das an der Universität aufgetaucht ist, und durch die Forschungsarbeit von den Smartcard Developers Association Leuten herausgefunden. Das heißt, die haben sich die unvollständigen Dokumente genommen, haben sich einen Chipkartenleser genommen, haben sich die Karte genau angeguckt und haben versucht jedes einzelne Detail in der Wirkungsweise dieser Karte zu rekonstruieren. Dann hatten die den genauen Algorithmus und haben sich den angeguckt und fanden, dass er nicht allzu sicher aussieht und haben den an eine weitere Gruppe geschickt. Das waren Dave Wagner und Ian Goldberg aus Berkeley, die dort beim ISA-Aktzentrum sind an der Universität. Die beschäftigen sich also mit Sicherheit, Verschlüsselung, Koptographie und so weiter. Und die haben festgestellt, dass es offensichtlich ein Problem bei diesem Algorithmus gibt. Denn wenn man eine solche Chipkarte hat und der Chipkarte Fragen stellen kann und dann die Antworten sieht, dann kann man den Schlüssel herausfinden. Also die prinzipielle Art der Attacke nennt sich eine Chosen Plain Text Attacke. Das heißt, ich wähle den Text, der da verschlüsselt wird, schicke den hin und kann mir das Ergebnis angucken. Und die genaue Schwachstelle bei dem Algorithmus war halt, dass man zwei verschiedene Sachen hinschicken kann und dann das gleiche Ergebnis zurückbekommt. Und für welche Werte man dieses gleiche Ergebnis bekommt, das hing bloß von wenigen Bits des Schlüssels ab. Das heißt, man konnte dann eine Weile Fragen hinschicken, bekam Antworten zurück und bekam dann irgendwann zweimal die gleiche Antwort. Das heißt, man bekam eine Antwort, die man schon gesehen hatte. Und mit der Information, welche Paare das waren, konnte man jetzt 16 Bits des Schlüssels bestimmen. Und insgesamt ist der Schlüssel 128 Bit lang. Das heißt, man hat das Ganze achtmal gemacht. Man braucht also ungefähr 20.000 Versuche für je 16 Bit. Das heißt, nach 150.000 bis 200.000 Versuchen hat man den kompletten Schlüssel aus der Karte extrahiert. Soweit die Überlegungen der Forscher in Berkeley.
Vielleicht sollte man noch dazu erwähnen, was das jetzt für ein Setup ist, was man dafür braucht. Die Karte fragen klingt irgendwie so einfach, weil so ein Handy hat ja zunächst einmal irgendwie nicht... Das hat keinen Stecker dran, wo man seinen Computer irgendwie ranstecken kann, wo man dann irgendwie mit der Chipkarte reden kann, was man halt... ja, okay, hat er schon. Also in diesem Fall wurde halt ein Chipkartenlesegerät verwendet. Das ist keine besondere Magie. Sowas kann man irgendwie kaufen. Sowas stellen ja auch zahlreiche Firmen her. Wir haben unseren eigenen Bau sozusagen verwendet. Vom CCC gab es mal so ein Projekt heißt UniProc. Das ist halt so ein universeller Kartenleser und Schreiber. Und dann konnte man halt mit dem Rechner direkt mit der Karte, also mit dem Chip auf dieser Karte, der ja ein eigener Computer ist, reden. Und eben diese ganzen Tests mit dem Key durchführen.
Okay, und die Leute in Berkeley haben das gemacht. Allerdings haben sie ihre Ergebnisse nicht vollständig veröffentlicht, sondern sie haben bloß auf der Webseite eine Kurzbeschreibung des Problems abgegeben. Das heißt gesagt, ja so und so sieht das mit den Anfragen aus. Das ist halt eine Collision, wenn zweimal das selbe Ergebnis auftritt. Es gibt da und da eine Collision. Das war die Information, die wir hatten zu dem Zeitpunkt. Und dann hatten wir uns natürlich auch schon vorher mit Chipkarten beschäftigt und auch GSM-Chipkarten. Wir hatten die Unterlagen darüber, wie diese Chipkarten mit dem Rest der Welt reden. Das ist nämlich einmal der ISO-Standard 7816, der alle Chipkarten spezifiziert. Also sei das jetzt Krankenkassenkarte, sei das EC-Karte mit Chip und Telefonkarte und die Karten, die man in seinen Premiere-Decoder reinschiebt und so weiter und so fort. Alles dasselbe Protokoll, alles ISO 7816. Und das öffentlich, das kriegt man in jeder Unibibliothek. Zusätzlich dazu gab es dann den GSM-Standard GSM 11.11, auch aus der Unibibliothek zu beziehen. Und der beschreibt, wie die genauen Kommandos für die Anwendung GSM aussehen. Das heißt, da steht drin, welche Kommandos man hinschicken muss, welche Files es auf der Chipkarte gibt. Eine Chipkarte ist im wesentlichen Dateisystem. Da gibt es Directories und einzelne Files in den Direktorien, die man reinschreibt und man liest. Und da stand also die komplette Spezifikation, die man mit der Karte redet, drin. Und da stand auch drin, wie man diese Zufallsdaten an die Karte schickt und sich die Antwort abholt. Okay, wir hatten jetzt alle Informationen, die wir brauchten. Wir hatten das Protokoll, das die Karte redet. Wir hatten eine Hardware dazu. Wir hatten die Information, wie der genaue Algorithmus funktioniert. Diese Referenzimplementation trägt den Namen Comp 128. Die wurde von einem kompletten Source Code veröffentlicht auf dem Netz. Sie ist bei www.scard.org. Dann habe ich mich hingesetzt, habe ein kleines Programm geschrieben, das Anfragen hinschickt, nach Collisions guckt und dann anfängt die Bits auszuwerten. Irgendwann haben wir dann festgestellt, aha, D2 ist betroffen, bei D2-Karten funktioniert das. Haben das über Nacht laufen lassen und hatten jetzt einen Key. Und dann gab es noch jemanden im Berliner Umfeld, der auch schon viel mit Smartcards gemacht hat. Der hat in seinem Repertoire noch einen sogenannten Inverse Reader gehabt oder auch Season Interface genannt. Das ist eine Schaltung, die man an seinen PC anschließt, in der man Chipkarten simulieren kann. Also man braucht einerseits den Chipkarten-Leser, den man in den Rechner anschließt und auf der einen Seite eine Chipkarte reinschiebt und das Gegenstück sozusagen, die man in das Handy reinschiebt und die Chipkarte vorspielt. Die braucht man dann für den zweiten Schritt, nämlich für die konkrete Simulation. Der hat sich hingesetzt, hat einen GSM-Chipkarten-Simulator geschrieben. Der war auch im Wesentlichen schon fertig, den hat er früher schon mal gemacht. Da mussten wir dann bloß noch den Comp 128 einbauen und hatten damit alles, was wir brauchten. Haben das in ein Telefon gesteckt, haben den Hörer abgenommen und haben festgestellt, wir konnten telefonieren.
Das heißt, da war in dem Moment, ich versuche mir das gerade einfach alles so vor auszuführen. Nicht, dass ich die ganze Sache in jedem Schritt verstehe, aber so prinzipiell, also ich könnte es nicht nachmachen, aber mir ist das jetzt schon alles klar. Und an dem Moment dann aber, wo du diese Karte simulierst, musst du eine Verbindung von deinem Computer zum Handy haben.
Es gibt zwei Schritte.
Die Simulation der Karte ist auf dem Computer eigentlich, in einem Programm.
Der Computer tut dann halt so, als wäre er die SIM-Karte.
Und da ist dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, dass so ein kleiner Stecker, der in den Kartenschlitz beim Handy dann reinkommt, oder so, stellen wir uns vor.
Genau, die Fotos sind auch bei uns auf dem Web-Server, weil da hängt halt so ein bisschen Platinengelumpe irgendwie an dem Handy dran, was halt irgendwie da reingeschoben wird, wo normalerweise die Karte dann...
Natürlich unterwegs und praktisch.
Die ganze Sache würde auch hardwaremäßig nachzubauen gehen, bloß das wäre dann jetzt der zweite Schritt, die Sache quasi für unterwegs vorzubereiten. Momentan geht die ganze Simulation mit dem Computer einfach besser. Und es lassen sich schnelle Änderungen vornehmen, wenn die Sache einmal hardwaremäßig quasi fertiggestellt ist, dann kann man da weniger ändern. Und das ist halt für die Experimentierphase nicht so gut geeignet.
Klar, es geht ja auch nicht darum, das wirklich zu machen, sondern es ging ja darum, es zu demonstrieren, dass es wirklich ist.
Diese Chipkarten, die in GSM-Handys drin sind und die zum Beispiel auch auf der Geldkarte mit Chips sind, das sind sogenannte Prozessorchipkarten. Also anders als Telefonkarten oder Krankenkassenkarten, wo einfach bloß Daten draufstehen, ist da ein richtiger Computer drin. Also eine CPU mit RAM, mit ROM und mit EEPROM und halt mit Möglichkeit mit der Außenwelt zu reden über ein serielles Interface, da sind die Goldkontakte oben drauf. Und ja, also aus dem PC mit der Kabel dran, so eine Chipkarte zu machen, ist im Prinzip bloß die Kunst des Weglassens. Und es gibt auch auf dem Markt bereits frei programmierbare Chipkarten zu kaufen. Das heißt, man müsste sich bloß so eine Karte besorgen, könnte die programmieren und hätte genau denselben Effekt. Die Karte würde sogar so aussehen wie eine normale GSM-Karte.
Sag mal, wenn so eine Karte, das war mir bisher nicht wirklich klar, du hast gerade gesagt, das ist so eine Art Dateistruktur eigentlich, die da auch drauf besteht auf so einer SIM-Karte. Das heißt, das sind Verzeichnisse und Files. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch einen Rechneranteil wahrscheinlich, noch in gewisser Hinsicht. Und weil ihr gerade von anderen Karten geredet habt, wenn ich so einen Karten lese und Schreibgerät hab, ist das dann theoretisch möglich, dass ich meine Krankenkastenkarte da reinpacke und die Adresse ändere?
Das ist theoretisch möglich. Das ist sogar praktisch möglich.
Das ist sogar ziemlich einfach.
Das ist überhaupt nicht schwierig. Und da fängt es halt auch schon mal wieder an, bei der Stelle, da können wir ja vielleicht auch noch mal drauf zu sprechen kommen.
Vielleicht sowieso dann auch noch mal eine Sendenung.
Vielleicht noch mal so zusammenfassend. Wir haben halt zwei Sachen gemacht. Wir haben drei. Das erste war, wir haben Kenntnis genommen davon, dass eben diese Algorithmen herausgefunden wurden, eine Schwachstelle dokumentiert wurde. Der zweite Schritt war, wir haben konkrete Software erstellt, die das nachvollzieht, die aus der Karte den geheimen Schlüssel rausholt, der der eigentlich das Heilige in dieser Karte ist. Und der dritte Schritt war, unter Kenntnis dieses Schlüssels einen Computer so zu programmieren, dass er sich gegenüber einem Telefon so verhält wie eine SIM-Karte, sodass sich das Telefon gegenüber dem Netz genauso verhält wie ein Telefon mit der Originalkarte.
Das war auch eine schöne Zusammenfassung.
Zu sagen wäre eventuell noch, dass man für solche Attacke natürlich die Karten-Pin braucht. Die ist dafür nötig und diese Untersuchung der Karte quasi mit dem Frage- und Antwortspiel dauert einige Stunden. Also das ist nicht innerhalb von Minuten getan.
Das ist aber...
Gucken wir jetzt schon langsamer auf die Konsequenzen.
Genau, da kommen wir auf die Konsequenzen. Und vor allen Dingen, wenn ich die Pinn-Nummer habe... Lauter oder leiser?
Red erst mal weiter.
Ich brauche die Pinn-Nummer von dieser Karte. Das macht die Sache natürlich einiges schwieriger. Selbst wenn ich Händler bin und da einen Haufen von Hunderten Karten habe oder Dutzenden Karten, habe ich ja nicht gleichzeitig die Pinn-Nummer. Dazu muss ich einen Umschlag öffnen.
Na ja, wenn du Händler bist, hast du natürlich den Umschlag. Und ich meine, jeder kennt das aus schlechten Filmen, dass Briefumschläge über Wasserdampf geöffnet werden. Und das funktioniert wirklich so. Also mit einem Föhn und einem Skalpell kann man diese Umschläge aufmachen. Dann kann man sie hinterher mit einem Bügeleisen wieder zumachen. Und dann sieht man eigentlich nicht, dass der Umschlag jemals offen war.
Denn da ist doch eigentlich die eigentliche Gefahrenstelle, oder? Mannesmann hat ja gleich gesagt, so what? Wenn jemand seine Karte verliert und dann auch noch seine Pinn-Nummer oder so, dann meldet er die halt sofort als gestohlen. Und damit ist er von der Haftung ausgeschlossen, was ja auch soweit stimmt. Aber es geht eben nicht nur darum, dass wenn ich meine Karte verliere, also deswegen, ich versuche das immer auf so ein ganz verständliches Level zu bringen, weil die Leute natürlich jetzt ihre Handys angucken und sagen, Hilfe, vielleicht telefoniert jetzt gerade einer auf meine Kosten. Kann natürlich theoretisch sein, aber durch die Entdeckung von solchen Geschichten, also in dem Moment, wo man öffentlich darauf aufmerksam macht, wird es natürlich auch schwieriger.
Das war ja die Reaktion von Mannesmann. Die haben halt gleich irgendwie in der Öffentlichkeit bekannt gegeben, das Ganze, was wir da demonstriert hätten, hätte im Prinzip die gleichen Konsequenzen, wie wenn die Karte, sozusagen das Handy, mit der Karte geklaut wird und die PIN bekannt ist. So, das mag nicht ganz falsch sein, aber wir sehen das natürlich noch ein bisschen anders, weil das ist nicht so... Beim Klonen ist es ja so, dass die Originalkarte zunächst einmal noch da ist, wo sie hingehört, sodass ein Liebstahl in dem Sinne gar nicht genau so festgestellt werden kann, als wenn die Karte geklaut wird. Also schon mal ein ganz entscheidender Unterschied. Der Punkt ist nun der, kann jemand mit einer geklonten Karte problemlos nebenbei telefonieren, während der andere sein Telefon ganz normal weiter benutzt. Und da gibt es so einige technische Probleme, die man noch zu berücksichtigen hat. Zum Beispiel können eigentlich nicht beide gleichzeitig eingebucht sein.
Also es funktioniert praktisch. Also der Trick ist halt, wenn man irgendwie seinen D2 Telefon plus Karte irgendwie jetzt schon seit ein paar Jahren hat, dann ist es tatsächlich wahrscheinlich relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass jetzt davon plötzlich Klons auftauchen. Aber was halt passieren kann, ist, dass eben diese Händler-Attacke wäre theoretisch möglich. Dass man eben sozusagen, wenn man sich jetzt eine neue Karte holt, dass man dann nicht 100% sicher sein kann, ob da nicht vielleicht schon die Pin bekannt ist und irgendwie der Schlüssel rausgeholt wurde. Und dann gibt es halt noch die andere Attacke. Das sind irgendwie Miettelefone. Also man kann sich ja auch Handys mieten. Oder die Autovermietungen haben halt größtenteils ihre Wagen auch mit Mobiltelefonen ausgestattet. Wobei das zum Teil auch Zennetz ist, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Wo die PIN-Nummern übrigens auch immer riesengroß draufstehen und vielleicht erst eingegeben werden müssen.
Besonders interessant für die Sache übrigens wären die zwei Callierkarten, wo es im Gegensatz zu anderen die zwei Karten keinen Einzelgebührennachweis gibt. Man kann sich quasi nicht nachweisen lassen, was man telefoniert hat. Es gibt darüber keine Rechnung. Man legt die Karte quasi nur auf mit dem 50 Mark oder mit dem 100 Mark. Und der Einzahlungsbeleg dient, falls man eine Rechnung braucht für das Finanzamt oder wofür auch immer, dient der Einzahlungsbeleg auf dem Konto-Auszug. Der Ausdruck dient als Quittnung dafür und man kriegt keine weitere Abrechnung. Dementsprechend wäre es da am problemlosesten möglich, nebenbei zu telefonieren.
Da stellen Sie natürlich noch eine ganze Menge andere Fragen, wenn ich an die gesamte Dateistruktur von dieser Karte rankomme. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie sowas abrechnet mit den Gesprächseinheiten und so, wie sowas funktioniert. Aber dann stellt sich natürlich die Frage, ob ich dann hier auch noch andere Daten manipulieren kann.
Das ist nochmal eine andere Geschichte. Die Abrechnung auch bei diesen Prepaid-Karten funktioniert zumindest in den deutschen Netzen in den Vermittlungsstellen, bei deren Abrechnungssystemen. Das heißt, das Netz guckt bloß, welche Karte bucht sich da ein, dann guckt es irgendwie auf seinem zentralen Rechner nach, wie viel Kohle ist noch auf der Karte drauf. Und wenn du dann damit telefonierst, dann wird das halt berechnet und abgezogen. Und an der Karte kannst du da gar nichts machen.
Beziehungsweise, die Kohle ist halt nicht, der guckt nicht, wie viel Kohle auf der Karte ist, sondern der guckt, wie viel Kohle sozusagen der Netzbetreiber noch diesem Kunden sozusagen zur Verfügung zu stellen. Und auf der Karte ist gar nichts gespeichert.
Es gibt ja nicht eine Möglichkeit, dass ich einfach, dass ich auf der Karte sozusagen dieses Gespräch zustande kommen lasse und dann aber, dass es auf der Karte vielleicht ein kleines Programm gibt, das sagt, aber es ist gleich wieder abgebrochen und in Wirklichkeit telefoniert es noch.
Die Vermittlungsstelle merkt ja sozusagen, ob du telefonierst oder nicht. Das wird halt nicht irgendwie mit dem Telefon oder mit der Karte ausgemacht, sondern die Vermittlungsstelle weiß halt einfach, dass du telefonierst.
Ich hatte gerade schon den Conrad-Katalog aufgeschlagen.
Falls jemand auswandern will, es gibt tatsächlich Länder, in denen das funktioniert, da ist das Guthaben tatsächlich auf der Karte gespeichert. Da gibt es auch eine einfache Möglichkeit, das sozusagen zu umgehen. Zwar haben viele Ericsson-Telefone die Möglichkeit, in ein pseudo-ausgeschaltet Modus zu gehen. Da gibt man eine bestimmte Tastenkombination ein, dann schaltet sich das Telefon äußerlich komplett ab. Das heißt, es ist kein Display mehr da, irgendwie die LED blinkt nicht mehr, gar nichts mehr. Man kann aber weiter telefonieren, das Gespräch, das man gerade aufgebaut hat. In diesem Fall, bei den Netzbetreibern, wo das tatsächlich auf der Karte gespeichert wird, wird das dann da nicht mehr abgerechnet.
Eine ähnliche Fehler gab es auch mal bei D1, bei den Prepaid Cards. Wenn das Guthaben dort abgelaufen war, das funktioniert aber inzwischen nicht mehr, konnte man das Gespräch, was man gerade aufgebaut hatte, noch weiterführen und zu Ende führen, wo das Guthaben abgelaufen war.
So, dann könnt ihr jetzt erstmal drüber nachdenken. In den Radio Fritzen heute nach Mittag wurde schon mal mit dem CCC telefoniert, um auch so ein bisschen auf diese Sendung hinzuweisen, um das Ganze natürlich auch nochmal zu beleuchten. Und die Radio Fritzen hatten auch versucht, mit Mannesmann darüber zu reden und einen Vertreter von Mannesmann zu kriegen. Die haben gesagt, wir haben überhaupt keine Probleme damit, da gibt es eigentlich gar keine Gefahr, die dadurch eintritt. Wir werden auch nichts ändern an den Karten, mit anderen Worten Mannesmann hat bisher gesagt, das kann sich natürlich alles ändern, dass sie das Verfahren auf den Karten nicht ändern werden. Das ist natürlich nicht ganz unerheblicher finanzieller Faktor. Selbst wenn man die alten jetzt lassen würde, gibt es da sicher eine Menge Karten, die schon auf dem Markt sind, die man austauschen müsste. Das alles soll also nicht stattfinden. Mannesmann sagt, kein Problem, was soll schon passieren. Was alles passieren könnte, können wir uns ja jetzt mal ein bisschen ausdenken.
Brauchen wir es gar nicht auszudenken, sind ein paar Sachen sehr naheliegend. Also das Hauptargument seitens der Netzbetreiber ist natürlich, es können ja nicht beide Karten doppelt eingebucht werden. Das wird sofort festgestellt und das kriegen wir sofort raus. Und das stimmt so zunächst einmal nicht. Was ist mit diesen Twin Cards?
Also Mannesmann und übrigens der eins auch verkaufen sogenannte Twin Cards. Das ist dafür gedacht, wenn man irgendwie ein Autotelefon hat und dann noch ein Handy, was man halt mit sich rumschleppt, dass man nicht jedes Mal, wenn man aus dem Auto aussteigt, irgendwie die Karte daraus nehmen muss und irgendwie ins Telefon friemeln, sondern man kriegt halt irgendwie von Mannesmann, wenn man das möchte, gleich zwei Karten zugeschickt. Das ist sozusagen zweimal die gleiche Karte oder sogar dieselbe Karte, die auch immer. Und damit kann man sich, also da steht halt drin, man darf sich irgendwie nicht gleichzeitig einbuchen und so Geschichten. Aber es geht halt theoretisch. Das ist quasi genau das Gleiche, weil da ist die eine Karte ein Klon vom anderen sozusagen. Und man kann sich halt tatsächlich gleichzeitig einbuchen. Die Anrufe, die reinkommen, kriegt dann halt immer das Telefon, was sich zuletzt eingebucht hat. Und abgehend kann man halt auch telefonieren von beiden Telefonen. Das einzige, wo es ein Problem gibt, ist, wenn beide gleichzeitig telefonieren. Dann führt das halt zum Gesprächsabbruch.
Achso, es geht nur um das gleichzeitig einbuchen. Das ist möglich.
Das ist auf jeden Fall möglich.
Aber zu gleich reden geht nicht.
Richtig, man kann nicht gleichzeitig telefonieren, aber gleichzeitig einbuchen. Da ist auch die Sache, wenn man von irgendjemandem eine geklonte Karte hat, könnte man zum Beispiel auch solche Sachen machen, wie dass man dessen Anrufe hijackt. Man bucht sich einen, nachdem der morgens sein Telefon angeschaltet hat. Und dann kriegt man halt dessen Anrufe.
Und er kriegt keine und merkt es nicht.
Genau, weil er kann ganz normal telefonieren, aber es ruft halt irgendwie keiner an.
Stimmt, also ich verstehe, der bucht sich einen morgens, ich buche mich danach ein, mache einen kurzen Anruf, damit die Anrufe bei mir ankommen.
Du brauchst nicht meinen Anruf zu machen.
Achso, einfach der, der sich als letzter angerichtet hat, kriegt die Anrufe. Und in dem Moment kehren alle Gespräche zu mir. Das ist natürlich eine schöne Abhörmöglichkeit.
Ich kann auf jeden Fall mir aber Verwirrung erzeugen.
Gibt ja Leute, die an sowas Interesse haben könnten.
Na ja, es gibt noch mehr Abhörmöglichkeiten. Dieser Algorithmus, der für die Authentifizierung verwendet wird, ist auch derselbe, der für die Festlegung des Schlüssels zur Sprachverschlüsselung verwendet wird. Das heißt, wenn ich diesen geheimen Schlüssel aus der Karte kenne, kann ich die Funkverbindung des Handys abhören.
Was vielleicht noch zu sagen ist, wenn man mit einem Handy, in dem seine Karte drin ist, seinen Anrufbeantworter abhören will, dann muss man ja seine Geheimzelle nicht eingeben. Da das Netz automatisch die Karte erkennt, kann man mit der geklonten Karte natürlich auch den Anrufbeantworter problemlos abhören, ohne dass man die PIN der Mailbox eingeben muss.
Auch noch wichtig, dann gibt es natürlich auch noch den Aspekt, dass jemand, der eine geklonte Karte hat, ohne dass der Hauptbesitzer das weiß, kann den natürlich sowieso in einige Schwierigkeiten bringen. Abgesehen jetzt von finanziellen Belastungen, die er mit den Gesprächen führt, sind ja vielleicht auch die Inhalte der Gespräche.
So sieht das aus, weil die Netzbetreiber oder die Strafverfolgungsbehörden werten ja seit einiger Zeit die sogenannten Bewegungsprofile aus, die man hinterlässt, wenn man sich mit einem eingeschalteten Mobiltelefon bewegt. Das wird gespeichert, wann man sich wo eingebucht hat. Damit ist immer so ungefähr der Aufenthaltsort zu bestimmen.
Diese Bewegungsprofile möchte ich bei einigen Leuten übrigens gar noch mal sehen. Auf einer Landkarte gehen die immer von zu Hause zu Aldi zurück.
Also wir würden unsere auch ganz gerne mal sehen. Uns ist auf jeden Fall klar, was man für interessante Sachen rauslesen kann, wenn man unsere Bewegungsprofile mal auswerten würde. Weil das wäre mit wem ist da so klar abzulesen wie die Stadtzeile auf der Bildzeitung.
Da hat es natürlich auch Fälle gegeben, wo es um solche Sachen ging wie zum Beispiel ein Mord oder so was in der Richtung oder ein Einbruch und wo dann einfach die Bewegungsprofile des Mobiltelefons von demjenigen ausgewertet wurden, der da irgendwie im Verdacht stand. Und das wäre natürlich, wenn man irgendwie mit einem Mobiltelefon herumläuft, was eine geklonte Karte hat und eingebucht ist, da könnte man sozusagen jemandem ein beliebiges Verbrechen, ein Mord oder sonst irgendwas in die Schuhe schieben.
Und die Beweislast wäre außerst kompliziert.
So sieht das aus, weil die Vermittlungsstellen wäre das halt irgendwie so abgespeichert und das gilt halt erst verbrieft, dass das dann so passiert ist.
Das ist mittlerweile von den deutschen Gerichten auch offiziell als Strafverfolgungsmittel anerkannt worden vor kurzem.
Der Netzbetreiber wird sich dann natürlich noch darauf berufen, dass ja derjenige mit der geklonten Karte eine geänderte E-Mail-Nummer gegenüber der Originalkarte verwendet. Jedes Telefon verfügt über eine sogenannte E-Mail-Nummer.
E-Mail heißt irgendwie International Mobile Equipment Identifier. Das ist sozusagen die Seriennummer des Gerätes, die jedes GSM-Gerät weltweit eindeutig identifiziert.
Genau und die wird neben den Karten-Daten, also neben den Daten von der Original und neben den Daten von der geklonten Karte, wird diese E-Mail, die Telefonnummer sozusagen, also die Hardware-Nummer von dem Telefon, auch noch mit übertragen. Aber selbst da lassen sich schon Dinge ändern. Man kann diese E-Mail-Nummer unter gewissen Umständen eventuell auch klonen. Sodass man sozusagen nicht nur die Karte desjenigen klont, sondern wenn man dessen E-Mail-Nummer von dessen Telefon weiß, kann man die in sein eigenes Telefon übernehmen, quasi sein Telefon klonen. Und dann hat man absolut identisch sein Gerät. Man hat die Kartendaten von ihm, man hat die E-Mail-Nummer von ihm, man hat sozusagen das identische Gerät.
Das Netz kann dann sozusagen nicht mehr unterscheiden, wer jetzt wirklich derjenige ist.
Sag mal, ich hab das nicht mitbekommen, dass Gerichte das jetzt offiziell akzeptieren.
Schon eine Weile.
Ich glaube, in der letzten Woche stand es auch noch mal im Spiegel.
Das ist was, was super abnervt, dass diese Sachen zurzeit, also in allen, im Bereich digitale Technik und gerade Kommunikationstechnik, dass die alle so klammheimlich passieren. Also sie stehen natürlich dann irgendwo mal in der Zeitung. Und ich glaube, wer richtig viel liest, der wird es wahrscheinlich auch im Vorfeld mitkriegen. Manche Sachen kriegt man ja durch Computerzeitungen mit. Oder eigentlich hauptsächlich durch eine Computerzeitung.
Weiß, es gibt ja ja noch die Datenschleuer.
Ja genau, aber die kommt dann meistens mit Verzögerung raus.
Wir sehen es immer pünktlich.
Aber da denke ich halt auch immer, dass diese Sendung hier äußerst richtig platziert ist bei Fritz. Weil, dass das alles so schnell gemacht wird, bevor es irgendwie ein großes Thema wird, das finde ich äußerst bedenklich. Aber das war jetzt nur ein kurzer Abstecher. Wenn ihr direkte Fragen zu diesem GSM-Hack habt, also nicht zum Mobiltelefonieren allgemein, weil da kommen wir gleich drauf, dann könnt ihr jetzt anrufen, wirklich nur ganz speziell zu dieser Geschichte. Dann gehen wir euch jetzt ein paar Minuten, euch hier zu melden und dazu zu fragen. Ansonsten, wenn da nicht so viele Fragen kommen, gehen wir davon aus, dass das jetzt jeder mitgekriegt hat, worum es geht und dass wir dann zum Thema Mobilfunk allgemein kommen.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Postan 70 97 1 1 0.
Scheinbar gibt es doch einige Fragen zum Thema. Allerdings nicht hier. Also der Fritz Webchat funktioniert im Moment nicht, weil ich hier keine Verbindung zum Netz kriege. Dementsprechend kann ich den nicht anschalten. Aber der Telnet-Chat vom Chaosradio, der müsste funktionieren.
Der sollte funktionieren, obwohl ich es auch nicht noch mal vorher überprüft hatte. Wir hatten da heute ein kleines Problem mit dem Server. Ich hoffe, das Problem hat sich erledigt. Schickt uns doch mal eine Nachricht.
Es funktioniert, ich hab den Server getestet. Das wollen wir tanzen.
Gib mal doch einfach mal die Adresse.
Du brauchst einen Telnet-Client dafür. Genau.
Okay, sag mal, andere Frage jetzt mit den Karten, mit eurem GSM-Hack. Wenn ich jetzt eine, ich hab jetzt gerade SMF angeschaltet, eine normale Telefonkarte habe, D2, dann kann ich die jetzt vom Prinzip her kopieren und habe dann praktisch eine Twin-Karte. Und dann kann ich die, meinetwegen meiner 6080 und meinem 6110, ganz normal einsetzen. Du musst eben aufpassen mit dem Einloggen, wie ihr es eben besprochen habt.
So sieht das aus. Du musst natürlich, also, du musst natürlich gucken, ob du das auf eine ganz normale Karte kopiert kriegst sozusagen. Also dann müsstest du halt noch ein bisschen basteln oder sonst eben dementsprechend immer haufenweise Elektronik mit dir rumfahren.
Naja, Elektronik rumfahren hab ich, hab ich keinen Bock, echt mal.
Aber...
Nein, du darfst das natürlich auch gar nicht machen. Das ist, das muss man ja auch mal kurz dazu sagen, dass das natürlich illegal ist.
Ich habe eine Twin-Tat, ich habe eine Twin-Tat bei mir jetzt hier. Von den zwei von Vorbei 97. Also 97 hat schon Sinn, ne? Und die funktioniert auch ganz gut. Bloß eben ist jetzt die Frage, was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich im Ausland bin, jetzt zu Hause jemand gerade mein Telefon anhat und ich mich in einem ausländischen Netz jetzt anmelde. Mit meinem Handy.
Naja, das funktioniert folgendermaßen. Du bist im Ausland oder der andere ist im Ausland?
Ich bin im Ausland, meine Frau ist jetzt mit meinem Auto unterwegs, hat jetzt das Handy an und ich schalte aus Versehen mein Auto, Telefon an und ich bin jetzt im Ausland, sage gut, jetzt muss ich telefonieren und jetzt schalte ich mein Handy an. Dann sind ja beide Karten mit meinem Netz.
So sieht das aus. Also dann ist es halt erst mal so, dass deine Frau dann halt keine Anrufe mehr kriegt auf der Nummer, weil du dann halt eingebucht bist und da du roams passiert Folgendes, das ausländische Netz, in dem du roams, das versucht halt deine Karte beim HLR von deinem Heimatnetz zu authentifizieren und casht diese Information dann, also speichert die zwischen in dem sogenannten VLR, in dem Visitors Location Register im eigenen Netz. So und was dann halt den Standards nach passiert, ist Folgendes, du kannst dich dann jeweils einbuchen in dem Netz und kannst telefonieren, weil es halt nach dem ersten Einbuchen nicht mehr die Information aus deinem Heimatnetz holt, sondern einfach die, die es sich gecashed hat benutzt. Und kriegst allerdings keine Anrufe und deine Frau in Deutschland kann sich halt auch ganz normal einbuchen und auch telefonieren. Das heißt, dann sollte es möglich sein, dass beide gleichzeitig telefonieren.
Aber wie sieht es denn aus, dann kriege ich keine Anrufe mehr. Aber meine Frau kriegt die dann.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Obwohl ich mich nachher im Netz eingebucht habe.
Genau, solange wie halt das ausländische Netz deine Daten aus dem VLR nimmt, weil dann weiß das Heimatnetz, also weißt das D2-Netz gar nicht, dass du dich in einem anderen Netz eingebucht hast, weil sozusagen da gar kein Kontakt zwischen bestand.
Zweite Frage noch dazu. Ich war jetzt gerade in Tschechien und habe es auch schon in Griechenland ausprobiert. Manche Netze unterstützen ja nicht die automatische Identifikation bei der Mailbox. Jetzt spricht D2. Wenn ich mich jetzt über das Netz mit der normalen Mailbox nochmal einwähle. Richtig. Gibt es irgendwo eine Liste im Netz, wo man mal gucken kann, welche Netze das unterstützen? Weil ich weiß, in Tschechien ist ein Netz, unterstützt es das andere nicht. Ja frag mich jetzt bitte nicht, welches. Es war irgendwann so zu Silvester. Dann gibt es irgendwie ein 1-Netz und irgendwie ein 2-Netz und das 1. Netz. Da musste ich da meine Geheimnisse eingeben, wenn ich die Mailbox angewählt habe. Und beim zweiten wurden diese Daten mit übertragen.
Vielleicht passiert das einfach über die... Also mir ist das Phänomen gar nicht bekannt. Ich musste bisher irgendwie aus allen Auslandsnetzen immer meine PIN eingeben, wenn ich meinen Anrufbeantworter abhören wollte. Aber das kann natürlich auch mit der...
Schön, dass man die vergessen hat.
Nicht wahr? Ja, wer die braucht.
Das kann natürlich auch mit der Ruf...
Da muss man die hotline anrufen, dann wird die Mehrbox zurückgesetzt, wenn man halt sämtliche Nachrichten verloren. Danke.
Das kann natürlich auch mit der Rufnummernübermittlung zu tun haben. Das heißt, vielleicht wurde aus dem einen Netz, also ich weiß nicht, ob du das überprüft hast, vielleicht wurde aus dem einen Netz keine Rufnummer übermittelt und aus dem anderen, wo du deine PIN nicht eingeben musstest, wurde eine Rufnummer mit übermittelt, weil die Authentifizierung passiert ja letztlich anhand der Rufnummer. Also das könnte sein, das ist halt ein möglicher Grund, ansonsten weiß ich nicht, was die da noch für Authentifizierung benutzen.
Also meine Ausdruck war mal auf Kreta direkt gewesen, da gibt es auch zwei Netze, beide haben es nicht unterstützt, das war allerdings jetzt vor einem Jahr her, dass es bestimmte Netzmerkmale gibt, die die jeweiligen Netzbetreiber irgendwie mitübertragen oder nicht übertragen. Und meine Rufnummer wurde glaube ich da von Kreta mit übermittelt. Ich kann es nicht garantieren.
Du kommst ganz schön rum, ne?
Ich bin Student.
Ach ja, guck mal an.
So als Student kann man sich ja so viel reißen.
Nein, nein, nein. Leute, also hab auch schon mal gearbeitet, gerade wieder auf Job-Suche und alles Mögliche. Und zu Kreta war ich halt mal im Praxissemester da und Tschechien liegt ja gerade um die Ecke, so mal zum Winterurlaub.
Ja, mein Gott, brauchst du ja auch dafür wirklich nicht rechtfertigen. War mit zwei zwingenden Augen bemerkt.
Jaja, Doppelpunkt, Minuszeichen, Klammer zu, Klammer zu, ja?
Genau, das geht ja im Radio gar nicht mehr heutzutage.
Ja, euer Chat ist ja im Moment noch nicht, also der Fritz Chat jedenfalls.
Ja, schlimm, ich weiß, ja, das ist richtig, kann man mal sehen, wie schnell man sich daran gewöhnt. Ich find's auch extrem schade.
Dafür haben wir ja heute den Chaos Chat, den kannst du ja auch mal ausprobieren, wenn du Telnet hast, dann...
Ja, ich habe so eine große Kiste, die hat auch Telnet.
Na bitte, dann bist du sozusagen schon dabei.
Unter welchem Namen bist du im Chat?
Ich bin unter Soundman.
Soundman?
Genau.
Alles klar.
Die kleine Firma, ne?
Achso?
Ja, war mal da.
Ist aber nicht dein Laden?
Nee, nee, ist immer noch von dem Herrn RR, ne? Rolf Ruff und der macht ja inzwischen gut mit seiner Kopierbar, ne? Musste einfach mal, wenn du dich in Kreuzberg auskennst, einfach mal die Hausnummer 113, gehst da ein nach links und dann bist du in der Kopierbar. Ja, ist doch klar.
Aber du bist da nicht mehr?
Nö, nicht mehr, nicht mehr. Aber die machen immer noch diese netten, kleinen, fiesen Geschichten mit CD's und so weiter und so fort.
Gott sei Dank sind wir hier unter uns.
Genau.
Und haben nach letzten Ermittlungen 100.000 Föder. Moment, Moment.
Wir hatten sogar ein Gehmal.
Ja, natürlich hat er den.
Aber seitdem man Philips Brenner modifiziert hat, ist es auch schon gar nicht so schlecht, sich so ein Teil zu holen.
Schlaudert.
Schlaudert aus dem Beekes.
Sag mal, ihr seid aber in Freundschaft auseinandergegangen damals, oder? Okay, ich dank dir. Also, bis denn. So, gibt's mal weitere Fragen zum GSM-Hack selber. Mal hier noch ein paar Leute gucken.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ja, hallo, da ist der Thomas aus Österreich.
Thomas aus Österreich?
Ja, ganz genau.
Und bist du gerade in Brandenburg oder hörst du uns von da?
Nein, ich bin in Österreich, Oberösterreich. Und ich wollte fragen, ob ihr vielleicht irgendwie schon recherchieren können habt, ob der Trick mit den D2-Karten auch in Österreich klappen würde.
Großes Interesse hier von unseren Nachbarländern.
Jaja, sowieso.
Also wir haben es nicht überprüft, aber es sieht so aus, als ob wohl ein Großteil der Netze weltweit einfach den Standard übernommen hat und damit für genau diese Attacke anfällig ist.
Aha, das wäre wahnsinnig interessant.
Ja, du kannst es natürlich selber ausprobieren. Du brauchst bloß einen Chipkartenleser und unsere Software vom Web-Server und die wird dir das dann sagen.
Ja, die hab ich schon. Ich bin schon am basteln.
Oder hast du auch schon einen Linux auf deinem Rechner?
Nein, noch nicht. Auf meinen noch nicht, aber in der Firma.
Seit wann gibt es das Netz in Österreich?
Bitte?
Seit wann gibt es das Netz in Österreich? Seit wann ist das online? Das GSN-Netz?
Seit 1991 gibt es das, was früher bei der Telekom war, bei der Post, das ist das A1. Und seit circa zwei Jahren gibt es das Max, das ist das Private.
Das ist beides GSM 900?
Das sind beide GSM 900, ja. Und wir haben auch noch ein analoges Netz, das heißt bei uns D-Netz. Und das ist auch, kurz unter 900 MHz, das ist ein ETAX-Netz. Das ist bei uns auch noch relativ stark verbreitet.
Ja, dann würdest du mal mit dem A1-Netz versuchen. Ich denke, da stehen die Chancen am besten.
Ja, genau.
Und gibt es auch einen GSM 1800?
Ja, kommt, das ist von Connect Austria. Und die Mobilcom, also der A1-Netz-Betreiber, möchte auch, also in den Großstädten zumindest, eine GSM 1800 Versorgung anbieten. Ich hab so ein Handy da, so ein PT-11-NF. Und ich hab's zwar schon probiert in unserer Landeshauptstadt, in Wien, beziehungsweise in Linz, aber nichts.
Würden wir denn natürlich noch Frohes basteln?
Und zwar, ich hab mir da einen bestellt, ich glaub, der heißt Tobikoto oder so ähnlich. Das ist irgendein so ein ausländisches Fabrikat, glaub ich.
Ansonsten guck einfach auf die Webseiten vom CCC und der www.ccc.de, da liegt Näheres zu dem und sehr prog der Kartenleser, mit dem der CCC das gemacht hat.
Ja, ich war eh zuerst schon im Chat super, muss ich sagen.
Okay, also der läuft zumindest. Weil wir haben hier keine Netzanbettung.
Ja, super, bei uns schon. Ich hör euch mit so starker Verzögerung, das ist gigantisch. Am Telefon sofort und im Radio 2-3 Sekunden.
Ja, wir haben damit auch schon mal rumgespielt, mit der Satellitenverzögerung. Man kann sich dann selber Fragen stellen, das ist sehr schön.
Ja, das ist wirklich.
Thomas, viel Spaß und Grüße.
Ja, danke, schöne Grüße zu euch nach Deutschland und weiter so.
Es kriegt so eine Internationalität auf einmal hier.
Na ja, es gibt jetzt auch einen Chaos-Treff in Wien, wenn ich richtig informiert bin. Näheres dazu auf unseren Webseiten.
Ich guck mal hier noch einen Anrufer, dann ist mit der Geschichte erstmal Schluss.
Hi, ich bin der Matthias.
Was ist denn, wenn ich den Pin ändere?
Eins, zwei, kann ich am Handy jederzeit machen? Und jetzt, wenn eine zweite Karte existiert, was passiert denn dann?
Das betrifft die zweite Karte nicht. Die Pin ist sozusagen bloß lokal für die Karte, wo du die Pin tatsächlich änderst. Und für den Klon brauchst du keine Pin.
Also die Pin wird halt nicht mit übers Netz übermittelt. Die hat mit der Netztechnik nichts zu tun, sondern die verwehrt halt oder versperrt halt sozusagen, wenn du sie nicht richtig weißt oder nicht richtig eingeben kannst, auf jeder einzelnen SIM-Karte bloß den Zugriff auf die Funktion, dass du halt zum Beispiel den Key da rausextrigieren kannst.
Es gibt übrigens eine theoretisch beschriebene Attacke, die praktisch noch nicht umgesetzt wurde. Und zwar ist es theoretisch auch möglich, diesen Key über die Funkschnittstelle zu extragieren. Das heißt, ich tue einfach dem Handy gegenüber, als wäre ich ein Netz und sende die ganz regulären Anfragen, wie auch das Netz sie sendet, bekomme darauf eine Antwort. Und irgendwann habe ich auf die Art und Weise auch den Key. Dazu brauche ich keine Pin. Dazu muss ich nicht in den Besitz der Chipkarte gelangen. Ich brauche bloß etwas aufwendigere Hardware und 12 bis 16 Stunden Zeit.
Ja, da ist uns jetzt natürlich eine hübsche Idee gekommen, wenn Leute außerhalb von Deutschland anrufen, dann haben wir natürlich eine Bitte an alle die, die uns jetzt über Satellit in anderen Ländern hören. Nämlich die Bitte.
Und zwar schickt uns eure alten SIM-Karten. Wenn ihr SIM-Karten habt von irgendwelchen Netzen, wo ihr noch die PIN habt, wo die Karten aber gesperrt sind, schickt uns bitte die Karten mit PIN und schreibt natürlich auch dazu welches Netz das ist und wir versuchen rauszukriegen, ob diese Karten von dem Problem betroffen sind oder nicht. Und wir werden selbstverständlich das Ergebnis dann auf unserem Webserver zugänglich machen.
Also wie gesagt, wenn ihr Karten habt, die können gesperrt sein und dann kann natürlich auch damit nichts passieren. Es geht einzig und allein darum zu gucken, ob man die auch klonen kann. Die schickt ihr dann an die Adresse, die auf den Chaosradio Seiten steht und wir können sie aber hier auch noch mal zum Mitschreiben angehen, also weil doch nicht jeder einen Internetzugang hat.
Genau, SIM-Karten hätten wir gerne an den Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Postfach 642860 in D1048, also 10048 Berlin.
Und ansonsten kommen die natürlich auch an, wenn man sie hier zu Fritz zum Chaosradio schickt. Die Fritz-Adresse wird ja öfter durchgesagt, die ist Fritz, das kann man dann auch zu Händen Johnny schicken, das bin ich. Postfach 90900 in 14439 Potsdam. So bis halb gucken wir mal noch, ob es hier noch interessante Fragen gibt zu diesem D2 Mannesmann Hack. Und dann nach dem Kurzinfo stürzen wir uns auf das Netz im Allgemeinen, das Telefonmobilnetz. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Meine Frage, könnte man den PIN-Code auch rauskriegen, indem man die ganze Angelegenheit beim Netz mithört, dass man im Prinzip die Fragen vom Netz oder die Antworten vom Telefon mithört und sich das darüber rauskriegt? Das dauert zwar ein bisschen länger, aber ist das vorstellbar?
Das ist leider nicht so einfach, weil die Fragen, die man an die Karte schicken muss, die haben eine spezielle Form. Man kann also nicht beliebige Sachen hinschicken, sondern man muss bestimmte Bits hochzählen und andere immer gleich lassen. Und einfach nur mithören wird wahrscheinlich nicht reichen.
Aha, also ist es von außen, sag mal, in jeder Hinsicht nicht oder schwerer zu knacken, denn im Prinzip keiner, den die Karte oder den Pin hatte?
Naja, es ist zumindest durch mithören nicht zu knacken. Du kannst natürlich aktiv angreifen, du kannst das Netz simulieren und selber die Fragen stellen, das geht.
Also, dass man sich im Prinzip bei irgendjemanden vor der Auszüge stellt und den Namen verscheißert, auf Deutsch gesagt.
Genau, aber dafür brauchst du halt relativ aufwändige Hardware.
Ach so, naja, gut, das war's gewesen.
Man kann ja den Fritz Üwe anmieten.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ah ja, da kann man wieder feststellen, wie schön Mobilfunk ist.
Wieder einen Anruf aus dem Cyberspace.
Sehr schön. So, hallo, noch eine Frage gibt's, falls du eine hast.
Hallo, ich bin Holger.
Hi Holger.
Ich hatte meine Frage. Ich hab vor uns noch den A8-Schlüssel erwähnt.
Was passiert mit dem eigentlich?
Also A8 ist der Algorithmus und das Ergebnis des A8 ist der Schlüssel, der für die Sprachverschlüsselung verwendet wird. Also nachdem du dich eingebucht hast, wird die Verbindung auf verschlüsselt geschaltet, nachdem diese Challenge-Response-Geschichte gelaufen ist. Und der Algorithmus dazu ist der A5. Und der Schlüssel für diesen Algorithmus ist das Ergebnis des A8. Also in Wirklichkeit sind A3 und A8 derselbe Algorithmus. Der liefert halt 12 Byte und man nimmt die ersten vier. Die gehen zurück ans Netz und die nächsten acht, die werden als Schlüssel verwendet. Nein, den haben wir nicht geknackt. Wir haben bloß beobachtet, dass in Deutschland dasselbe zutrifft wie in allen anderen GSM Netzen. Das haben die Leute von Eskart herausgefunden, dass von dem Schlüssel für die Sprachverschlüsselung, also diesem A8-Schlüssel, die letzten zehn Bits immer auf Null gesetzt werden. Und das kann nur einen Sinn haben, nämlich das Abhören leichter zu machen. Und das tritt auch bei allen Netzen auch davon. Davon ist nicht nur D2 betroffen, davon ist auch D1 betroffen, davon ist auch E plus betroffen. Und das Schlüssel wird von 64 auf 54 Bits künstlich verkürzt. Und dazu kommt, dass der A5 kein besonders sicherer Algorithmus ist. Das heißt, den normalen A5 mit 64-Bit-Schlüssel kann man mit ungefähr 2 hoch 45 Aufwand knacken. Das heißt, ungefähr alle Rechner in einer Uni für zwei Tage. Aber jetzt durch die Kenntnis des verkürzten Schlüssels kann man das noch weiter drücken und möglicherweise in einen Bereich bringen, wo man, wenn man programmierbare Hardware hat, solche Geschichten im Sekundenbereich die Verschüssen knacken kann. Na, die 10 Bits werden ja von der Chipkarte auf Null gesetzt. Das heißt, es müssten sämtliche Chipkarten getauscht werden. Genau das wollen die ja nicht machen, weil das für jeden einzelnen Teilnehmer eine Mark Porto und 10 Mark für die Karte kostet. Und bei geschätzten 8 Millionen GSM Teilnehmern in Deutschland kann sich jeder ausrechnen, was der Spaß kostet.
5 Millionen sind es, aber trotzdem ist es eine ganze Menge.
Wie viel davon, der 2?
2 Millionen D2 in etwa, 2 Millionen D1 in etwa und in etwa 1 Million E+.
Kann man sich darüber streiten, auf jeden Fall sind es eine ganze Menge.
Also hier sollte man vielleicht nochmal etwas zusammenfassen. Also was sozusagen festgestellt wurde.
Vor allen Dingen sollte man klarstellen, dass diese Schlüsselverkürzung höchstwahrscheinlich nicht von den Mobilfunkbetreibern oder von den Netzbetreibern eingebaut wurde, sondern dass es von Geheimdiensten oder ähnlichen Organisationen gefordert wurde, dass das eben gemacht wird, um das Abfällen zu erleichtern.
Genau.
Musik hier übrigens im Chaosradio heute im Computer Balloon bei Fritz. Nach wie vor von Simplicity of Sound und nach dem Fritz-Kurzinfo-Gleich wird es auch mal ein bisschen einen längeren Take von den Jungs geben, damit man auch mal besser hört, was die eigentlich machen.
Wenn Fritz im Raum anger mündet, dann 100, 1.
23, 30 übrigens.
Ultimatum, die Balkan-Kontaktgruppe hat Serbien aufgefordert, unverzüglich Gespräche mit den Kosovo-Albanern aufzunehmen. Sollte dies nicht bis zum 9. Mai geschehen sein, würden alle jugoslawischen Guthaben auf ausländischen Konten eingefroren. Klimaschutz. Deutschland und die anderen 14 EU-Staaten haben heute das UNO-Protokoll von Kyoto unterzeichnet. Darin verpflichten sich die Industrienationen, den Ausstoß von Treibhausgasen bis zum Jahr 2012 auf das Niveau von 1990 zu senken. Leerstellenstreit. Das Bundeskabinett hat den Berufsbildungsbericht 98 verabschiedet. Minister Rutgers geht davon aus, dass jedem ausbildungswilligen Jugendlichen eine Lehrstelle angeboten werden kann. Die SPD warf ihm Beschönigung vor. Eingeständnis. Der Verfassungsschutz hat Defizite bei der Bekämpfung des Rechtsextremismus in Ostdeutschland eingeräumt. In Brandenburg und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern seien Ausländer deutlich höher gefährdet als in den alten Ländern. Partnersuche. Drei Tage nach der Landtagswahl gab es heute in Sachsen-Anhalt erste Gespräche über eine neue Landesregierung. Spritzenpolitiker auch, aber Spitzenpolitiker der SPD trafen sich nacheinander mit Vertretern von CDU und PDS. Macht ja nichts. Fußball. Die Ergebnisse der Bundesliga. Härter BSC-Verloh bei Bochum 1 zu 2. Bielefeld und Kaiserslautern trennten sich 2 zu 2. Das gleiche Ergebnis gab es zwischen Leverkusen und Dortmund und Schalke gewann gegen Köln 1 zu 0. Gute Nacht, einzelne Schauer, örtlich Nebel, 12 bis 8 Grad.
Wette.
Ah, liegen uns nicht vor die Hinweise, deshalb rote Fahraut.
Nein, nein, man weiß es mit dem Fritz-Korz-Info.
Heutzutage gibt es ja eine Menge Nauten. Astronauten, Cybernauten, Kosmonauten, Aquanauten, Aeronauten, Radionauten und die Elektronauten.
Ein wunderschöner Soundtrack für diese Sendung heute von den beiden. Und ansonsten ja, so ist das in Blue Moon im Allgemeinen und so ist das natürlich auch beim Chaosradio. Wird viel geredet, so dann also auch in dieser Ausgabe. Wir uns jetzt ein bisschen im Allgemeinen mit den Mobilfunknetzen beschäftigen. Was uns außerdem noch beschäftigt ist, ihr könntet mal anrufen, wenn ihr vielleicht Techniker seid, die mit Mobilfunknetzen zu tun haben, Endgerätetechniker oder mit dem Netz selber arbeitet, dann wäre das sicher auch mal spannend, sich mit euch zu unterhalten. Die Fritz-Telefonnummer sollte ihr da kennen inzwischen. 0331, das ist in Potsdam. Für die Leute, die aus dem Ausland anrufen, die müssen danach davor noch die 49 wählen.
Und die Null weglassen.
Und die Null weglassen natürlich. Also 0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110. Und dann ein bisschen Geduld haben, weil das natürlich bei den zehn verschiedenen Telefonen, die hier rumstehen, alle ein bisschen länger dauern kann. Weil dieser Hack jetzt mit den D2-Karten, war das das erste Mal, dass im Mobilfunknetz in irgendeiner Form gehackt wurde?
Eigentlich gab es die Hackversuche schon seit es Mobilfunknetze gab.
Das Problem war halt bloß bei den Mobilfunknetzen. Es fing ja an mit dem A-Netz, dann ging es weiter mit dem B-Netz. Das war 60er, oder?
60er war A-Netz, da hast du den ganzen Kofferraum voll gehabt.
Was hat denn damals so eine Minute Gespräch gekostet?
Ich weiß nicht, das war sowieso handvermittelt alles und...
Also es gab das B1-Netz, soweit ich informiert bin. Das ist Handvermittlung gewesen. Das B2-Netz, das war so Ende der 70er, das war dann das erste Selbstwahlnetz. Das Problem war bloß, dass die Hardware kofferraumfüllend war und die Geräte breitsundendlich. Und dementsprechend gab es halt einfach nicht die Geräte im Umlauf, um sich damit zu beschäftigen und die zu hacken. Also es gab damals halt im B-Netz eine Minimalzahl von Teilnehmern. Das war halt wirklich nur so der Regierungsdirektor und der Konzernchef. Die hatten halt irgendwie Autotelefon und das war's. Richtig los ging die Sache mit dem C-Netz. Wobei im Nachhinein noch zu sagen ist, das B-Netz wurde vor einigen Jahren abgeschaltet und zum Ende des B-Netzes hin gab es dann natürlich auch die riesigen Geräte, die keiner mehr haben wollte und das Netz lief aber noch. Und die Hardware dieser Geräte war dermaßen simpel aufgebaut, dass sie sich wirklich mit Heimwerkermethoden hacken ließen.
Also da war halt einfach keine Sicherheit eingebaut, weil das war halt einfach nicht nötig.
Da waren zum Teil Schalter drin, die man halt umlegen konnte. Da hatte man eine andere Kennung in dem Gerät drin und konnte auf andere Rechnungen telefonieren. Da gab es auch noch keine SIM-Karte, die drinsteckte, sondern die Kennung war halt entweder über Schalter oder über E-Proms hardwaremäßig in dem Gerät programmiert. Und es gab zum Ende des Netzes hin, als die Geräte dann billig im Umlauf waren, auch diverse Supports für 119-Nummern zum Beispiel, wo von gehackten Geräten kostenpflichtige Rufennummern angerufen wurden, um quasi da Geld einzusacken und ähnliche Geschichten. Und das Netz wurde dann einfach abgeschaltet.
Und das ist, hatten wir nur noch das C-Netz, was analog war.
Genau das C-Netz war schon ein wenig fortschrittlicher als das B-Netz. Das Gespräch selber lief zwar nach wie vor analog, das heißt über eine normale Funkstrecke. Man konnte das mit jedem handelsüblichen Radioempfänger abhören. Aber der Gesprächsaufbau selber war schon digital. Allerdings war es da auch so, dass nur eine Kennung übermittelt wurde. Die Kennung steckte zwar in einer Chipkarte bzw. am Anfang einer Magnetkarte drin, wurde aber unverschließend übers Netz verschickt. Man konnte auf der Funkstrecke die I.D.s mithören, konnte die in sein Telefon einprogrammieren, das war dann schon etwas aufwendiger, ging aber auch noch und konnte dann damit telefonieren. Irgendwann haben sie dann die Magnetkarten abgeschaltet, hatten nur noch Chipkarten und haben dann eine ähnliche Challenge-Response-Geschichte wie jetzt beim GSM eingeführt, wo man das Daten vom Netz durch die Chipkarte jagen und zurück schicken muss, bevor man telefonieren kann. Es gab also auch im C-Netz eine Zeitlang die Möglichkeit, um sonst zu telefonieren. Irgendwann haben sie halt dieses zusätzliche Sicherheitsfeature eingeschaltet und seitdem hatte, glaube ich, keiner mehr richtig los, sich damit zu beschäftigen. Jedenfalls ist mir nichts zu umgekommen seitdem.
Ansonsten gibt es halt noch in Amiland irgendwie zum Beispiel die analogen Netze nach dem EMS-Standard und diversen anderen, wo das auch ähnlich möglich ist wie im B-Netz. Also da gibt es noch nicht dieses Chipkarten-Konzept, weil die halt auch schon relativ alt sind. Da ist halt auch das Telefon mit der Rufnummer sozusagen direkt verbunden oder repräsentiert die Rufnummer. Und da kann man auch in den meisten Fällen relativ einfach die ID ändern und dann auf andere Leute Kosten telefonieren, zumindest theoretisch, weil es da halt inzwischen so ist, dass die Telefongesellschaften dann halt ihre Polizei los schicken und die halt relativ schnell Leute finden, die sowas versuchen. Das dann halt meistens relativ unerfolgreich ist. Allerdings, das ist auch noch ein interessanter Aspekt mit den GSM-Netzen jetzt in den USA, dass halt den Leuten gar nicht so richtig klar ist, warum sie jetzt eigentlich auf GSM wechseln sollen und was daran eigentlich so viel besser ist. Und das einzige Feature, was GSM da halt wirklich hat, was man den Leuten auch klar machen kann, was deutlich besser ist, ist eben die Sicherheit. Und deshalb werben die ganzen GSM-Netzbetreiber in den USA mit ihrer überragenden Sicherheit und denen hat natürlich dieser Hack jetzt auch ziemlich wehgetan.
In den USA übrigens Cellularphones zu hacken, ist immer noch etwas mehr mit Konsequenzen verhaftet als in Deutschland. In den USA wird das ziemlich hart bestraft. Also wer da irgendwie Cellulars klont oder so, zumindest die Analogen, der geht ziemlich schnell hops. Bis hin vielleicht, um noch andere Länder zu nennen, in China wird Cellularcloning mit der Todesstrafe unter anderem bestraft. Und da sind sie jetzt richtig hinterher, da das schon mal ein wirklich ernsthafter zweig der Kriminalität ist. Und die da wohl ziemliche Einbußen haben. Ansonsten ist noch zu sagen zu den Hacks in den diversen Netzen und auch zu Endgerätehacks, das ist immer eine Sache der Verbreitung. Deswegen ist das C-Netz auch nie richtig gehackt worden, weil es halt nur in Deutschland und dieselbe Technik noch in Portugal installiert ist. An GSM sitzt halt die ganze Welt, weil es ist halt weltweit installiert. Dementsprechend interessieren sich auch entsprechend ausreichend Leute dafür. Die sitzen in Indien dran, die sitzen in Australien dran, die sitzen inzwischen in den USA dran. Das ist natürlich was anderes, als wenn nur ein paar Leute in Deutschland daran sitzen. Und dementsprechend gibt es da halt auch mehr Fortschritte als bei Netzen, die nur auf lokaler Ebene installiert sind.
Ich will nicht mehr reden, ich will jetzt noch zuhören. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaosradio. Nochmal Holger.
Ja, ich hab noch eine Frage zu dem Insy-Catcher, der von rote in schwarz angeboten wird. Mit dem soll es ja möglich sein, die Insy zu ermitteln. Mir ist aber eigentlich bekannt, dass nur die Titsi über die Luftschneestelle übertragen wird. Wie funktioniert das Ganze?
Na, es ist so, dass der Insy-Catcher... Er erklärt erst mal, was Insy-Catcher ist. Die Insy ist die Seriennummer der Chipkarte. Das ist sozusagen die zweite Information, außer dem Schlüssel, den man braucht, um mit der Karte zu telefonieren. Und wenn man die Insy kennt, weiß man, wer da telefoniert. Das heißt, man kann, wenn man die Richtfunksstrecken abhört, die ja unverschlüsselt sind, rauskriegen, wer da gerade telefoniert. Und wenn man also jemanden bestimmten abhören möchte, braucht man die Insy und man braucht Zugriff auf die Richtfunksstrecke. Und der Insy-Catcher, der spielt jetzt dem Telefon ein Netz vor. Das heißt, es ist eine komplette Netzsimulation und das Handy versucht sich einzubuchen, teilt dem Netz erstmal die TMS-Emit, die Temporary Identity und daraufhin sagt das Netz Fehler und dann sagt das Telefon naja okay und meine Insy ist so und so. Und naja, das Problem bei der ganzen Geschichte ist, dass das Netz sich nicht der Karte gegenüber identifiziert. Das heißt, die Karte muss dem Netz beweisen, dass sie echt ist, aber umgekehrt muss das Netz der Karte nicht beweisen, dass es echt ist und das ist auch so eine Schwachstelle im GSM.
Ja, aber wenn ich die Richtfunktstelle abhören soll, das wäre dann wesentlich kompliziert. Das ist ja was anderes als die UN-Schnittstelle. Die normale Funk-Schnittstelle zünden den Handy und der BTS.
Das ist richtig, aber der Insy-Catcher hilft dir nicht dabei, die normale Luftschwindstelle abzuhören.
Achso, also klingt sich der Insy-Catcher in die Richtfunktstelle an?
Nein, der Insy-Catcher läuft über die normale Luftschwindstelle des Handys und spielt ein Netz vor. Und wenn ich dann die Insy habe, um aus der Insy sinnvolle Informationen zu gewinnen, brauche ich Zugriff auf die Richtfunktion, die Strecke. Die sind ein paar Meter höher, aber da gibt es Nebencollen, es gibt auch die fertigen Protocol Analyzer zu kaufen, die bewegen sich natürlich in selben Preisregionen wie auch der Insy-Catcher. Aber für sechsstellige durchschnittliche Beträge ist man schon dabei bei dem Spaß.
Na ja, weißt ja was du morgen kaufst, ne?
Nein, brauch ich nicht.
Holger, dank dir.
Aufgelegt.
Gut aufgelegt. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Uwe, hallo.
Ja, und zwar habe ich mal eine Frage zu diesem Sicherheitssystem, und zwar bei einer Sprachübertragung. Ich habe zuvor angesprochen, dass da 10 Bits runtergefahren werden. Und wenn ich mir jetzt praktisch mir selber einen Klon ziehe, kann ich da diese Bits wieder hochfahren, also den Standard wieder erhöhen, oder funktioniert das denn nicht?
Das kannst du leider nicht machen, weil nämlich auf der Netzseite ja genau derselbe Prozess passiert. Und der Schlüssel, den das Netz verwendet, der hat die 10 Bits auf Null gesetzt. Und wenn du jetzt deine Bits anders setzt, dann kannst du natürlich mit dem Netz nicht mehr reden, weil der Schlüssel nicht mehr der gleiche ist.
Ah, siehst du? Frage, Antwort, so einfach kann es sein. Ganz überrascht, wenn man da einfach sagen kann. Hallo.
Jo, hallo, hier ist der Jörg.
Hallo, hast du ein Radio an?
Ja, jetzt hab ich's aus. Ich hab ja schon längere Zeit probiert und irgendwie hab ich vor kurzem eure Telefonanlage gehackt. Ich weiß nicht wieso. Ich hab plötzlich zwei, drei Minuten lang den Sender über Telefon mitgehört.
Ja, das passiert, wenn ich dich hier reinstelle. Also in dem Moment, wo ich, ich hab hier eine Leiste mit zehn Knöpfen, wo ich die einzelnen Gespräche sehe, wenn sie ankommen und ich kann dich praktisch sozusagen schon auf Sendung stellen und dann liegt dein Gespräch aber noch mal auf einem Regler. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo du reingestellt bist, hier schon ins Studio, hörst du dann Radio über das Telefon und aber erst wenn ich den Regler hochschiebe, hört man dich. Aber nice try.
Warum sind dann eigentlich die Karten von D1 und E plus sicherer? Haben die den anderen Schlüssel ab fünf, der also nicht diesen Fehler aufweist, dass er nach 16 Bit dort schon irgendwas falsch gibt? Oder gibt es da noch einen Unterschied in den Schlüsseln?
Na, es ist bei D1 und E plus so, dass die Algorithmen da nicht bekannt sind. Das heißt, die fahren genau dasselbe Sicherheitsschema, das auch D2 hatte. Wir bauen da irgendwas ein, wir erzählen keinem, was es ist. Und dann kann natürlich auch keiner sagen, ob das sicher ist oder nicht. Das heißt, die Antwort heißt da. Es kann passieren, dass das morgen gehackt wird. Es kann noch zwei Jahre dauern. Es könnte auch sicher sein. Das kann man aber nicht entscheiden. Na, er ist nicht wirklich gut Auslese geschützt. Aber was man tun muss, ist schon direkt die Karte aufmachen und dort auf dem Chip an das ROM und an das RAM gehen und ROM und RAM direkt vom Chip auslesen. Du kannst das nicht durch das normale Interface oben drauf machen, sondern musst direkt dran gehen. Dazu brauchst du halt schon relativ aufwendige Hardware, die normalerweise bloß in der Chip-Herstellung eingesetzt wird.
Vor allem würde es keinen Sinn machen, da der Schlüssel auf jeder Karte unterschiedlich ist. Du könntest halt mit gewissem Aufwand so eine Karte reingenieren. Dann hättest du halt von dieser Karte, die du gerade zerstört hast und unterm Rastamikroskop angeguckt hast und den ROM ausgelesen hast. Davon hättest du halt den Key. Aber von jeder anderen Karte hättest du ihn wieder nicht. Und das nützt halt nichts. Das ist ja kein universeller Schlüssel, der für alle Karten zutrifft, sondern die Karte hat halt ihren individuellen Schlüssel.
Ah ja, gut, ich würde zwischendurch vielleicht noch mal kurz die Verkehrspunkte machen, also zwischen Pelsig und die ESA, das Gentin, sonst wo. Es gibt Nebelwaden unter 10 Meter Sichtweite. Das ist ein sehr unschillender Moment. Da sollte man also ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ja, danke für den Hinweis und dann vervorsichtig.
Und nicht am Steuer telefonieren.
Ja, ich hab die ganze Sache, ich spreche nicht mehr zählen Gott.
Sehr vernünftig.
Ja, ich verdiene mein Geld auch, damit dass ich beim GSM-Netzbetreiber arbeite und bin dort auch, ich habe mein Netz hier zu Hause auch selbst geplant. Ich weiß also genau ungefähr was das abgeht.
Darf man fragen für welchen Netzbetreiber?
Oder welche Farbe ihr verwendet? Das langt ja auch schon.
Welche Farbe?
Na ob grün oder magenta oder blau oder?
Wenn ich das richtig mitgekriegt habe, hatten wir einen sehr komischen Turkis. Ich habe es gar nicht wiedererkannt, aber da bin ich nicht mehr. Sondern man beschäftigt sich jetzt schon wieder mit dem nächsten Netz.
Was machst du da?
Eine Funkplanung, was so Ausleuchtungen und so weiter betrifft.
Also du bist bei D07 hier?
Ja, richtig. D07 ist ein Fehler vom Handy. Das wird schon richtig ausgestrahlt. Aber die einzigsten Handys, die das richtig anzeigen, sind Ericsson Handys und Motorola.
Da brauchen wir immer eine relativ neue Softwareversion, oder?
Also Motorola zeigt es nicht, an jeden Fall nicht als Trebbler.
Ja, wenn man die falsche Karte hat, zeigt es natürlich nicht an. Man muss eine buchen. Also jetzt beim reinen Netzcannen geht es natürlich nicht.
Ein buchen ist ja derzeit noch etwas schwierig. Und wie weit ist das Netz?
Ich denke mal, es startet jahremäßig Ende Sommer wie Annika nicht.
Und hat dieses neue Netz über das Thema Sicherheit nachgedacht oder eher nicht?
Oh, dann nochmal bitte.
Hat dieses neue Netz über das Thema Sicherheit nachgedacht, wollen die jetzt ihre Algorithmen von vornherein veröffentlichen? Weißt du da was drüber?
Ich denke mal schon, dass man sich Gedanken macht. Und man kann ja noch alles ändern. Ich denke mal schon, dass man den höchsten Standard ansetzt, den es derzeit in der Praxis hat. Da muss ich natürlich sicherlich noch anders halten, weil das allgemein funktioniert. Das Roaming und so weiter muss ja auch gehen. Ich denke mal, dass man sich da auch an bestimmte Sachen halten muss, das ist einfach.
Hast du Informationen darüber, ob das Netz, von dem wir reden, eigene Endgeräte anbieten will, sowie E-Plus Endgeräte unter eigenem Logo anbietet, oder ist das in dem Netz nicht vorgesehen?
Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber ich vermute mal schon, weil das gehört immer meistens dazu. Man verkauft ja nicht bloß einfach eine blanke Karte, wie die Treffelkarten oder sowas, sondern wer auf der Treffel geguckt hat und die Handy sich richtig angeguckt hat, die waren ja schon mit einem richtigen Level belabelt. Also ich denke mal, warum soll das denn nicht auch so kommen? Übrigens, wie gesagt, wer das schon mal den Klang sich angehört hat, es ist kein Unterschied mehr festzustellen gegenüber ESCN.
Machen die dann auch Enhanced Full Rate?
Ja, das machen diese neuen Handys ja teilweise alle schon. Ja, 61, 30 und so.
Vielen Dank und weiter gute Fahrt, wenn es auch langsam ist. Könnt ihr uns jetzt mal einweihen, von welchem Netz wurde da geredet?
Also es wird halt ab Ende Sommer diesen Jahres ein viertes GSM Netz in Deutschland geben, auch wieder nach dem GSM 1800 Standard, also der Standard, den auch E+, verwendet. Und von Viac Intercom wird das Netz sein. Das, was man bisher E2 nennt, so im Sport.
Da ist halt noch nicht klar, was für ein Sicherheitsschema die verwenden.
Das war doch auch eine sehr gute Antwort von ihm. Ich denke, da macht man sich Gedanken drüber, da ruft morgen der Chef an und sagt, gut gemacht.
Es wäre halt ein sehr interessanter Schritt, wenn sich ein Netzbetreiber dazu durchringen könnte, eben auch diese, in Einführungsstrichen, geheimen Algorithmen von vornherein zu veröffentlichen und zu Diskussionen zu stellen, wie das ja im Internet gang und gäbe ist. Und sich auch als wunderbar überlebensfähig behauptet hat, nur Algorithmen, die alle Leute wirklich unabhängig bewerten können und wo sie die vollen Informationen darüber haben. Nur darüber kann man wirklich eine Aussage machen, ob das sicher ist. Wenn uns irgendein Netzbetreiber erzählt, sein Netz ist sicher, wie das ja auch in den letzten Tagen der Fall war, dann können wir da halt nur den Kopf schütteln, weil solange die uns nicht erzählen, was sie da machen, können wir da auch keine Aussage zu treffen. Sicher ist es dann, wenn es irgendwie öffentlich dokumentiert ist und die meisten intelligenten Köpfe dazu nicken.
Warum hat der Herr am Telefon da gerade gesagt, dass die Qualität so viel besser sei, wenn es eigentlich dieselbe Technik ist?
Enhanced Full Rate ist halt eine neue Sprachkompression, die mit einer höheren Datenrate gefahren wird. Und dadurch hat man halt wesentlich bessere Gesprächsqualität, also fast ISDN Qualität. Und das muss halt auch von den Endgeräten unterstützt werden und von den neueren Ericsson Geräten, also 788 und 688 mit neuerer Softwareversion. Und das jetzt kommende 888 wird unterstützt und sonst von Nokia bei den Geräten von der 61er-Reihe. Und bei den anderen Herstellern weiß ich das nicht so genau, aber auch bei E-Plus ab Sommer, wie es heißt, wird man dann halt dieses Enhanced Full Rate benutzen können.
Benutzen die die gleichen Bandbreite wie die derzeitigen Handys beim Datenverkehr?
Nee, die benutzen eigentlich genau dieselbe Bitrate wie bisher, bloß einen anderen Kompressionsalgorithmus. Ursprünglich war vorgesehen, dass dieser Full Rate Algorithmus, der jetzt drin ist, durch einen Half-Rate Algorithmus ersetzt wird, der nur die halbe Bandbreite benötigt. Dann haben sie aber irgendwann festgestellt, dass sie eigentlich genügend Netzkapazität haben, aber die Sprachqualität zu schlecht ist. Und was sie jetzt machen, ist, den Algorithmus, der ursprünglich für Half-Rate geplant war, doch mit der vollen Rate zu fahren, und dann haben sie mit derselben Bitrate eine bessere Sprachqualität.
Und das mit der Half-Rate wird aber trotzdem gemacht, allerdings nicht in den 1800er Netzen, weil da halt im Allgemeinen Genügendkapazität zur Verfügung steht. Da gehen sie jetzt halt auf Enhanced Full-Rate. Und in den 900er Netzen wird das nach und nach kommen. In einigen anderen Ländern ist das schon so weit, dass die halt dann zwangsweise auf Half-Rate umstellen, weil sie halt nicht mehr genügend Kapazitäten haben, weil ein 900er Netz eben weniger Kapazität hat.
Klingt dann aber noch genauso gut.
Naja, so ähnlich halt.
Hat das irgendwelche Auswirkungen auf Datenübertragung auch?
Nee, Datenübertragung ist immer mit 9600 BPS.
Da wird sich auch nichts dran ändern.
Naja, es wird halt schneller werden mit der Zeit.
Naja, es gibt jetzt derzeit eine Planung für Kanalbündelung, sodass man auf mehreren ESDN-Verbindungen gleichzeitig übertragen kann. Das heißt, man kann dann auch Vielfache von 9, 6 bis glaube ich 64 Kilobit nutzen. Wird demnächst eingeführt und irgendwann, wenn alles besser wird, wird es UMTS geben und da wollen sie dann glaube ich zwei Megabit machen.
Vielleicht der richtige Moment, nochmal auf unsere Webpages und sonstigen Dienste hinzuweisen. Chaos Computer Club hat seine Website unter www.ccc.de und Chaos Radio hat auch seine eigene Website unter chaosradio.ccc.de, wo auch immer Ankündigungen sind für die nächsten Sendungen. Wir haben daraus noch eine Meldungsliste, den Chaos Radio Ticker. Dort kann man sich eintragen lassen und dann bekommt ihr Ankündigungen zu den anstehenden Sendungen zugeschickt bzw. auch Feedback nach den Sendungen, die auf uns zubekommen sind. Und Kommentare zur Sendung grundsätzlich in die Mail chaos.orb.de. Wir möchten gerne hören, wie euch Chaos Radio gefällt und was ihr euch so für Themen wünscht.
Warum? Das wollen wir auch von euch wissen. Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio.
Wer ist denn da?
Timo.
Ich habe nur eine ganz kurze Frage zu eurem D2-Hack.
Du kommst ziemlich schlecht an, wenn ich glaube, dieses Geld macht irgendwie zu früh zu. Kannst du ein bisschen lauter reden?
Also die PIN-Nummer, warum man die nicht einfach hacken kann?
Ja, die PIN-Nummer darf nur dreimal eingegeben werden. Nach dreimaliger Eingabe ist die Karte gesperrt.
Da währt sich die Karte dann.
Man kann dann noch mit der Puck, das ist eine 10-stellige PIN-Ensperrnummer, falls man die dreimal falsch eingegeben hat, die Karte entsperren. Da gibt es aber auch eine 10-Möglichkeit, nie einzugeben. Und wenn die 10-stellige Zeit an 10 Mal falsch eingegeben wird, dann ist die Karte richtig dicht. Dann muss man eine neue Karte beantragen mit dem Netzbetreiber.
Das war's.
Danke.
Ciao.
Und wer ist da? Ach Burkard, der Gurke.
Ich bin Ulrich Richard Kaufmann Heinrich Anton Richard Dohrer.
Entschuldigung, wir haben hier Leute, manchmal bemunen die ersten Birne, deswegen noch die Werke.
Ja, der Birne, ja gut, sehr. Vielleicht gibt es auch eine Gurke.
Nee, nee, ganz bestimmt ist nicht. Wo ich anfangen will, ich hatte es vorhin gesagt, die Bewegungsdaten, um Bewegungsprofile zu erstellen, werden die grundsätzlich gespeichert, weil das ist ja ein riesiges Datenaufkommen. Da würde ja beim jeden Location Update ein Datensatz erzeugt werden.
Passt alles auf eine 4?
Der irgendwo verwaltet werden müsste.
Das ist gar nicht so viel.
Das sind ein paar Gigabyte maximal.
Das passt auf eine ganz normale 4 Gigabyte Platte, wie für einige Wochen und Monate, was in Deutschland so abgeht. Und was eine 4 Gigabyte Platte kostet, weiß ich.
Um die Frage zu beantworten, ja, es wird grundsätzlich gespeichert.
Also das hängt nicht irgendwie mit Maßnahmen nach, da fahren die Meldüberwachungsverordnungen zusammen. Das ist also grundsätzlich so, ja?
Das ist grundsätzlich so. Und ich weiß es nur für die Schweiz, da sind es 15 Tage, die das gespeichert wird.
Das ging ja auch um die Welt sozusagen, was da in der Schweiz los war.
Aber in Deutschland werden auch Bewegungsprofile erstellt. Und wie lange die nun gespeichert werden, wissen wir für deutsche Netze nicht genau.
Ja, das ist klar. Möglicherweise hängt das auch mit der grundsätzlichen Speicherung von Verbindungsdaten zusammen, dass das gleiche ist, gleiche sind.
Also die Bewegungsprofile sind nicht nötig um in irgendeiner Form die Abrechnung oder so?
Nee, das ist klar. Da wären ja dann bloß die Kennungen der BTS, die Zell-IDs wahrscheinlich gespeichert. Dann noch die zweite Sache. Ich halte es gar nicht für so wichtig, dass die Bit-Länge einer Luftschnittstelle verkürzt worden ist. Weil ich sag mal, wenn Profis in der Verbindung abgehört werden, hat man ja ganz andere Möglichkeiten. Ihr habt die Richtfunkstrecken erwähnt. Die sind ja auch faktisch an jeder anderen Stelle im Netz, außer an der Luftschnittstelle, unverschlüsselt, die Daten.
Das ist richtig. Aber dazu musst du dann ja auch genau wissen, wo das Gespräch langgeht, über welche Festnetz-Richtfunkstrecke oder welche andere Richtfunkstrecke das jetzt gelootet wird.
Ja, jetzt höre ich sicherlich nichts Neues, dass laut Schadensmeld über Wachungsverordnungen in sämtlichen Schnittstellen, in sämtlichen Switchen implementiert ist, dass Gesprächsdaten ausgekoppelt werden können müssen.
Naja, es gibt ja noch mehr als nur die staatlichen Behörden, die eventuell am Mithören interessiert sind, nämlich zum Beispiel die staatlichen Behörden anderer Länder oder kriminelle Organisationen oder Firmen, die vielleicht um denselben Auftrag kämpfen wie eine andere Firma und so weiter und so fort.
Na gut, also die würden sich dann sicherlich eventuell über einen Satelliten die Streustrahlung der Richtungsstrecken vornehmen.
Wenn sie über so viel Geld verfügen. Ich meine, was man preiswert haben kann, dafür muss man keine Satelliten hochschießen.
Das ist auch richtig.
Und vor allem, das andere was du beschreibst, die Möglichkeiten sind halt so die Regelfälle, wenn alles klappt, aber wenn man die Sprachverschlüsselung schon auf diesen einen kurzen Wege so stark einschränkt, dann kann man halt im Notfall auch brachial innerhalb von 20 Minuten, wenn man das richtige Equipment dahin bringt, sofort ein Ergebnis haben. Und das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Dimension als wenn über irgendwelche gerichtlichen Bescheide und bitte geben sie mir Zugriff auf die und die Nummer, das Ganze abläuft.
Also sag ich mal, jetzt für einen Einsatzfall, Terrorismusbekämpfung oder soetwas.
Wie man das heutzutage so nennt, ja.
Aha, ist klar, dann sollte das funktionieren.
Broke, was machst du beruflich?
Ich beschäftige mich mit solchen Sachen auch.
Auch beruflich?
Im Moment nicht so sehr stark beruflich, weil ich mein Tätigkeitsfeld gewechselt habe. Ich habe mich aber, sag mal, über zwei Jahre etwa.
Du wolltest weg von der Polizei?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein, du wolltest hin.
Nicht in dem Bereich. Wir haben ganz konkret Messtechnik für den Bereich gemacht.
So wie Rode und Schwarz?
So kamen wir. Na, Rode und Schwarz ist ein erster in der Luftmitstelle. Wir haben uns mit all dem, was in dem Netz dahinter passiert, beschöpft, verfasst.
Was ist alles für Berufsbilder? Was macht man denn da in der Messtechnik für Mobilfunk? Ihr macht dann so Aufträge, die dann ausgewertet werden?
Nein, eine ganz, ganz konkret Protokollmesstechnik für den SS7-Bereich. Aber dann auch natürlich alle Mobilfunk Schnittstellen, die in irgendeiner Art und Weise leitungsgebunden sind.
Aber mehr mit der Netztechnik beschäftigt ihr euch mit den Endgeräten nicht, oder?
Nein, also alles, was sozusagen jenseits der BTS oder eigentlich jenseits der A bis Schnittstelle ist, Richtung Candy, das interessiert uns da nicht mehr. Deswegen waren für mich die Sachen jetzt auch ganz interessant, dass eben die Angriffsmöglichkeiten auf A3, A8 und so weiter, das ist ja immer das, was auch immer gesagt wird, Security by Obscurity, an den Stellen, es doch ganz interessant ist, dass es solche Lücken dann doch gibt.
Kennst du dich ein bisschen aus mit A und A bis? Ja. Was mich interessiert, wenn ich in einem fremden Netz eingebucht bin und rohme, werden ja die Datensätze mit einem Key und mit der Challenge und der Response vom HLR in das ausländische Netz geschickt.
Ja.
Laufen die irgendwo über eine A oder eine A bis Schnittstelle, diese Daten oder landen die im MSC?
Also die landen maximal im MSC und da in einem Paul-R, was da dran hängt. Also über eine A-Schnittstelle sollten die nicht mehr laufen.
Sollten nicht oder tun nicht? Sollten sie nicht oder tun sie nicht?
Die Netzimplementierungen, die wir kennen und die wir auch getestet haben, dort gehen sie nicht über eine A-Schnittstelle.
Ich glaube, das war eine der spannendsten Dialoge, die ich angehört habe.
Das ist ja auch immer die Frage gewesen, sind die Identitäten an den Stellen, wo Richtfunksstrecken abhörbar sind? Das ist der eigentliche Punkt an den Sachen. Und ihr habt vorhin schon mal UMTS erwähnt, es kommt ja auch das GPRS jetzt, also innerhalb des UMTS ist ja die Datenübertragung dann mittels GPRS. Das wird ja dann faktisch auch Internet über Handy mit richtiger Paketvermittlung werden. Dann wird es wirklich, was die Bandbreite angeht, wirklich spannend.
Alles wird gut.
Alles, weil wir in Nepal sind.
Was heißt denn das?
Zumindest unser Mobilitätsproblem erst mal gelöst.
Was werden das für Geschwindigkeiten dann sein?
So wie du schon gesagt hast, also maximal die 2 Megabit, in Anpassung faktisch an die Festnetzleitung, die es da geben, die es ja dann im Festnetz gibt. Mehr macht ja dann keinen Sinn. Dann wird man einfach sehen, wie die Netze mit ihrer Kapazität zurechtkommen. So wie du schon gesagt hast, die 800 haben einen großen Vorteil, ohne immer nicht die Menge von Kanälen bereitzuhalten, und die können sich eben auch Kanalbündung leisten. Während die 900er ja doch etwas knapp sind an der Stelle.
So, und kannst du jetzt noch ein Datum sagen bitte?
Den letzten Wert, den ich kenne, ist endgültige Markteinführung 2002. Oder Jahreswende 2001, 2002.
Ja, hab ich auch gehört.
Also in den Dimensionen, meine man prügelt sich ja noch in den Spezifikationsgremien, aber in dem Fall wird wirklich alles gut dann. Nichts zu danken. Tschau, dir auch.
Bringt mich gleich auf den Punkt, vielleicht nochmal unseren Donnerstagstreff zu erwähnen, den wir hier im CCC Berlin machen, alle zwei Wochen. Und wir Donnerstags halt so... So Menschen, die sich kreativ mit Technologie beschäftigen, so wie wir das eben auch tun und versuchen. Die würden wir halt gerne dort begegnen. Die Informationen sind bei uns auf der Website.
Wie sind denn diese Treffen überhaupt Donnerstags?
Na ja, das ist entspannte Atmosphäre. Man trifft sich halt, lernt sich so kennen. Leute bringen ihre Computer mit. Man unterhält sich halt über dies und jenes, was gerade anliegt.
Also ist es wie ein Kindergarten, aber mit Computer und Kinder.
Sandkasten mit Strom. Wir machen jetzt allerdings auch mehr oder minder regelmäßig immer so kleine Workshops zu unterschiedlichen Themen. Das sind halt keine großen Vorträge, aber es gibt dann unter anderem immer noch ein bestimmtes Thema, was dann konkret vorgetragen wird, wo man im Dialog über die Technik geht. Nächstes Mal zeigen wir ein bisschen Reverse Engineering, zum Beispiel der D-Box, also dieser kleine Fernseh-Decoder, den so viele jetzt haben. Da kann man auch lustige Spiele mit machen. Das ist dann am 7. Mai, also Donnerstag, nächste Woche.
Und sind da viele Chaosradio-Hörer?
Na ja, es sind da auf jeden Fall auch Chaosradio-Hörer. Also ich hab sie jetzt nicht durchgezählt. Also ich frag mich ja nicht jeden Tag nach so einer.
Nächsten Donnerstag die Chaosradio-Hörer nach links, die anderen nach rechts. Da kann man prozentual... Wie ist der Männer-Frauen-Verhältnis?
2-3 Frauen auf eine nicht übersehbare Anzahl Männer.
Das haben wir in jeder Kneipe. Der DJ ist halt hier die ganzen drei Stunden im Chaosradio bei Fritz, die ganze Zeit von Simplicity of Sound. Wir haben uns heute noch ein paar Sachen ausgedacht. Ja, man kommt auf ganz komische Ideen manchmal. Ich mache jetzt hier noch den einen Anrufer, den ich jetzt hier schon die ganze Zeit hat warten lassen.
Andreas, hallo.
Drei Fragen. Die SM-Karte hat eine Rufumleitung programmiert im Auto. So, jetzt schalte ich mein Handy an und habe eine andere Rufumleitung programmiert. Was passiert?
Die letzte? Nein, nein, nein. Und zwar ist es ja folgendermaßen, dass die Rufumleitung, die wird im Netz aktiviert. Damit hat dein Telefon nichts zu tun. Das setzt sozusagen bloß den Request ab. Aktiviere jetzt mal eine Rufumleitung für mich. So, und das passiert in der Vermittlungsstelle. Das heißt, dein Telefon weiß an sich überhaupt nicht, dass du irgendwas umgeleitet hast. Wenn du da irgendwie eine Statusabfrage machst, ob deine Rufumleitung an oder aus ist, da holt er sich die Antwort vom Netz. So, und wenn du dich jetzt mit deinem zweiten Telefon mit derselben Karte einbußt, andere Karte, Tönenkarte, ja, also mit quasi der anderen, aber der gleichen Karte, dann weiß das Telefon gar nichts davon. Das Telefon hat damit auch nichts zu tun. Das heißt, wenn du dann da deine Rufumleitung abfragst, die sind dann halt genauso gesetzt, wie du sie das letzte Mal gesetzt hast, egal von welchem Telefon.
Es passiert also vom Prinzip her immer im Netz.
Genau, Rufumleitung passiert ausschließlich im Netz und das Telefon fordert das sozusagen nur an.
Also das heißt, wenn ich jetzt praktisch im Auto eine Rufumleitung programmiert habe, weiß ich nicht, alle anrufe zu mir auf die und die Nummer, mit dem Handy eine Anrufumleitung, alle Anrufe auf die Mailbox, dann ist die Rufumleitung, die das letzte eingeschaltet wurde, im Netz aktiv.
Genau.
Nächste Frage ist, wie sieht es denn eigentlich mit den Gebühren aus, wenn ich jetzt jemanden anrufe im D2-Netz und da kommt, der Teilnehmer ist zurzeit nicht zu erreichen? Zahle ich dafür vom normalen Telefon oder nicht?
Nee, da zahlst du nichts für. Also das ist eine Inband-Ansage, die halt geschaltet wird und da ist noch kein Anruf aufgebaut. Der Anruf ist immer noch in der Call-Progress-Phase und dafür kriegst du nichts berechnet. Also erst in dem Augenblick, wo tatsächlich der Anruf zustande kommt, fängt halt auch die Gebührenzählung an. Du zahlst ja auch nichts dafür, wenn du ein Besatzzeichen kriegst oder eine Ansage, kein Anschluss mit dieser Nummer oder so.
Wie ist das eigentlich in Österreich? Da war es eine Zeit lang so, dass man auch fürs Besatzzeichen gezahlt hat.
Ja, in Österreich zahlst du generell schon für den Verbindungsaufbau. Das ist ein völlig anderes System. Aber das gibt es, soweit ich weiß, nur in relativ wenigen Ländern und das ist halt auch echt schlecht, weil sowas wie zum Beispiel, du kannst halt keine für den Anrufer kostenfreien Nummern, wie hier die 130er oder 0800er einrichten und so eine Geschichten, also das wird aussterben.
Dritte Frage, wie sieht es dann eigentlich aus, wenn man euch einfach mal so im Studio besuchen möchte?
Im Studio?
Ja, muss man da ein Notebook mit haben und dann irgendwie CCC draufschreiben und dann sagen, ich gehöre dazu und sie ist ein Notebook.
Das braucht man natürlich nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Also das Problem ist jetzt, wenn ich jetzt zu dir sage, das kann man sicher mal machen, dann habe ich morgen 20 Postkarten und noch mehr E-Mails. Es ist wirklich super klein hier. Das heißt also, wenn wir noch zwei Leute extra hier drin hätten, dann wäre es wirklich unangenehm.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich kenne die ORB Studios nicht.
Nächstes Jahr machen wir Chaosradio aus der Waldbühne mit 30.000.
Also im Studio besuchen ist wirklich extrem schwierig, zumal auch das Ganze hier sowieso schon immer so ein bisschen unruhig und chaotisch sind, weil wir so viele Leute sind. Und ich glaube, wenn dann noch jemand dazukommt, ich glaube, das wird dann noch nervöser.
Vom Prinzip her? Nein. Musste dir schon einen guten Hack einfallen lassen.
Das soll man sich verdienen hier, Andreas. Aber es ist natürlich überhaupt kein Problem, alle Leute, die hier beteiligt sind, irgendwie zu treffen, am Donnerstag nämlich bei diesen Treffen. Ich denke, wenn man da...
Ich fang demnächst in Berlin irgendwo am hackischen Markt bei einer großen Firma, die heißt PSI. Kannst du sie ausrechnen, also PSI an. Und dann, wenn ich mal sehe, dann bin ich auch öfter mal wieder in Berlin. Werd ich demnächst bei euch vorbeischauen.
Ja, genau. Und ich denke, wenn man sich dann da zum Beispiel gut kennenlernt oder so, dann ergeben sich verschiedene andere Sachen.
Genau. Muss einfach ein Mitglied werden. Jetzt kommt noch die nächste Frage, die hattet ihr schon mal in der letzten Sendung. Da hab ich sie schon mal gestellt. Jetzt inzwischen auf dem Markt sind doch Handys, die jetzt doch deckt und GSM machen sollen. Ja oder nein?
Klarer Antwort. Also es ist halt... Von Ericsson gibt es jetzt halt das TH688. Das GH688 ist das für ganz normal GSM900. Das TH688 ist eben die Variante mit GSM900 und deckt. Ich weiß nicht. Ich hab das Gerät zum ersten Mal auf der Cebit gesehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das überhaupt schon verkauft wird.
Das wird in Deutschland noch nicht vertrieben, soweit ich informiert bin.
In Deutschland kommt das erst zum Ende des Jahres, wenn die Telekom dann ihre integrierten Mobilfunk und Festnetzangebote machen will. Dann braucht man ja so ein Gerät sozusagen.
Und wie buchen die um und aus? Deckt heißt das System, das man zu Hause hat, ohne Kabel, bei einem schnullosen Telefon. Und GSM ist klar, es sind Mobilfunknetze. Geht das automatisch?
Also wahrscheinlich wirst du nicht irgendwie... Also wenn du zu Hause bist, dann geht das über Deckt. Sobald du aus dem Bereich rausgehst, geht es über GSM. Aber von dem, was ich gehört habe, wird es nicht möglich sein, sich da automatisch umzubuchen. Das heißt, du kannst sozusagen nicht telefonierend aus dem Haus gehen.
Weil ich weiß, dass mein Deckt irgendwie funktioniert, bis zum drei Blöcke weiter.
Ja, dann kannst du halt nicht mehr als drei Blöcke weiter telefonierend gehen.
Gut, andere Fragen...
Es kommen ja noch Decknetze dazu.
Eventuell.
Oder ich telefoniere auf einmal einem anderen Decknetz natürlich aus.
Da war letztens in der Newsgroup.de, Mobile Geräte etc. Eine Frage auf der CeBIT, oder eine Antwort auf der CeBIT. Umbuchung von dem rüben D007 oder E2 Netz ins GSM Netz mittels Handy automatisch. Ist das eigentlich möglich, oder? Also Umbuchung von GSM 1800 auf 900.
Ähm, ja, also, ja, das ist möglich. Also, ähm, das würde... Und zwar gibt es ja in einigen skandinavischen Ländern halt schon, zum Beispiel auch in Hongkong, gibt es ja Netze, die halt auf dem Land 900 Megahertz sind und in der Stadt wegen der größeren Kapazität 1800 Megahertz. Und da hat man halt Dual-Band-Geräte und mit denen funktioniert, also ich hab's nicht selber ausprobiert, aber von dem, was ich gehört habe, funktioniert da halt auch das Handover zwischen den verschiedenen Standards.
Während des Gesprächs?
Während des Gesprächs.
Und mit der Datenübertragung bei den Handys, ihr hattet das ja schon angesprochen, bei den 1800er Netzen, da ohne Probleme, Kanalbindung und so weiter und so fort, wie sieht es denn eigentlich bei den 900er Netzen aus? Wird da was gemacht, ist da was bekannt? Oder bleibt es da immer noch bei den 96ern?
Es ist beides GSM, die werden das irgendwann einführen.
Irgendwann?
Wann weiß die Bundesregierung oder so?
Naja, die Netzbetreiber im besten Fall. Wenn die es nicht wissen, glaube ich, weiß es derzeit noch keiner.
Also da ist im Moment noch keine Chance, dass man jetzt sagt, ok, spezielle Einweihnummer und jetzt Internetüberschritte.
Also es gibt noch keinen Grund, unruhig im Sessel hin und her zu schubbern. Also alles kommt auf uns zu.
Es spießt noch viel Wasser, die sprechen nun da.
Genau, das ist verstanden.
Und Elbe, Andreas, dank dir. Okay, bis dann.
Ciao.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Anger nun wird, dann 100, 1.
Mario, wie spät ist denn eigentlich?
Ultimatum, die Balkan-Kontaktgruppe hat Serbien aufgefordert, unverzüglich Gespräche mit den Kosovo-Albanen aufzunehmen. Sollte dies nicht bis zum 9. Mai geschehen, würden alle Investitionen in Jugoslawien gestoppt. Mit sofortiger Wirkung wurden bereits Guthaben im Ausland eingefroren. Deutschland und die anderen 14 EU-Staaten haben gestern das UNO-Protokoll von Kyoto unterzeichnet. Darin verpflichten sich die Industrienationen, den Ausstoß von Treibhausgasen bis zum Jahr 2012 auf das Niveau von 1990 zu senken. Lehrstellenstreit. Das Bundeskabinett hat den Berufsbildungsbericht 98 verabschiedet. Minister Rutgers geht davon aus, dass jedem ausbildungswilligen Jugendlichen eine Lehrstelle angeboten werden kann. Die SPD warf ihm Beschönigung vor. Eingeständnis. Der Verfassungsschutz hat Defizite bei der Bekämpfung des Rechtsextremismus in Ostdeutschland eingeräumt. In Brandenburg und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern seien Ausländer deutlich höher gefährdet als in den alten Längelnan... Ländern, soll es sich ja heißen. Partnersuche. Drei Tage nach der Landtagswahl gab es gestern in Sachsen-Anhalt erste Gespräche über eine neue Landesregierung. Spitzenpolitiker der SPD trafen sich nacheinander mit Vertretern von CDU und PDS. Fußball. Die Ergebnisse der Bundesliga. Hertha BSC verlor bei Wochum 1 zu 2. Bielefeld, Kaiserslautern trennten sich 2 zu 2. Das gleiche Ergebnis gab es zwischen Leverkusen und Dortmund. Schalke gewann gegen Köln 1 zu 0.
Wetter.
In der laufenden Nacht Nebel, 2 bis 8 Grad. Tagsüber meist sonnig, dann und trocken zwischen 20 und 25 Grad. Verkessensweise liegen uns momentan nicht vor. Fritz wünscht gute Fahrt.
Und mein neuer Mann war das mit dem Fritz Kurz.
Fritz präsentiert eine amtliche Aktion zur Rettung bedrohter Arten.
Oha, fast vergessen, dass hier noch eine Sendung läuft gerade. Schön Musik gehört, bisschen geplaudert.
Ach ja, stimmt, da ist ja noch Sendung.
Und zwar noch 24 Minuten lang bis 1 Uhr läuft hier noch Chaosradio bei Fritz. Wir haben euch über den GSM D2 Hack ausführlich berichtet. Wir haben über Mobilfunk im Allgemeinen ein bisschen geredet, auch so ein bisschen über die alten Netze, auch darüber, ob da schon vorher Hacks entstanden sind. Was ist eigentlich mit Pagern? Also mit Quick Tell Me, Scroll, gibt es da irgendwelche Hacks, kann ich nicht irgendwie rumfummeln mit dem Computer und dann einem Scrollbesitzern was scrollen?
Na ja, bei Pagern ist es ja grundsätzlich erstmal so, dass die auch alle nicht verschlüsselte Arbeiten sind, also relativ leicht abzuhören. Die Software dafür für PC mit Soundblaster und der Windows kann man aus dem Internet downloaden, dann braucht man auch einen passenden Empfänger für 70 cm, auch für wenig Geld zu haben. Und man kann dann beliebige Pagerdienste mitlesen, das heißt gegen mitlesen sind die alle nicht gesichert. Man kann mit dieser Software auch Pogsack ausstrahlen, aber das sollte man einfach nicht tun, weil die das nicht gut finden und natürlich auch feststellen und einen relativ schnell peilen können, dann hat man einen Haufen Ärger am Hals. Aber theoretisch geht auch das. Und naja, weitere Probleme sind jetzt zum Beispiel mit dem Scroll aufgetreten, da hat sich die Pinnummer des Scalls aus der Telefonnummer errechnet, die Fort Pinnummer, wenn man die nicht geändert hat, dann konnte man die berechnen und dann konnte man den Pager von jemand anderes auf eine andere Nummer einbuchen.
Das heißt, das kann man immer noch?
Kann man immer noch, richtig.
Dann gibt es einfach eine Konstante, das ist glaube ich 6296. Wenn man das von seiner Scrollnummer abzieht, dann hat man ziemlich sicher seinen Pinn, den man sozusagen am Anfang zugeteilt bekommen hat. Und die kann man natürlich ändern, aber wenn man sie nicht ändert, wie das viele Leute wahrscheinlich tun, braucht man von jemandem nur die Nummer wissen, zieht 6296 ab, dann hat man die Pinn, kann irgendwie bei 0168, 0 Rufnummer und so weiter, gibt man da die Pinn ein und kann dann halt alle Einstellungen vornehmen. Zum Beispiel die Pinn ändern. Das wäre dann gleich das Mieseste. Auch wieder mal nicht nachgedacht, so ist es so traurig, dass sie dann nicht darüber nachdenken, was sie da machen. Sie müssen sich auch echt nicht wundern, wenn sie die ganze Zeit einen dahinter hinkriegen. Das wissen sie nicht. Also POG sagt, was Andreas gerade erwähnt hat, POG sagt P-O-C-S-A-G, das ist sozusagen der Standard, nachdem alle Pager hier funktionieren, egal wie sie heißen, Quick Tell Me, City Ruf, Skyper, Skoll, das ist im Prinzip alles die gleiche Grütze. Sie werden halt nur zu unterschiedlichen Konditionen verkauft. Das Mitlesen ist halt schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren die Regel. Man sollte auf jeden Fall davon ausgehen, dass alles, was man über seinen Pager empfängt, bei 10, 20, 30, was weiß ich, vielleicht 100 Leuten, irgendwo auf der Festplatte landet, die einfach alles mitschreiben und sich ihren Spaß draus machen, da ihre Informationsrecherchenprogramme drüber laufen zu lassen, um wer mit wem Beziehungen rauszukriegen. Zum Beispiel gibt es auch einen schönen Fall aus den USA. Ein Hacker aus der Gruppe um die Hackergruppe 2600, eine Art TTC in den USA. Wo war das in Pennsylvania? Da war Clinton zu einer Veranstaltung geladen. Die haben konsequent den ganzen Bereich abgehört. Auch der Secret Service, die ganzen Sicherheitsleute, die um den Clinton rumgelaufen sind, benutzen einen normalen Pager. Die haben alles mitprotokolliert und Analysen drüber gefahren, auch wer mit wem. Es gibt ein Internet zum Nachlesen, das ist sehr interessant. Da haben sich die Security-Leute gegenseitig für den Abend im Hotel verabredet und solche Sachen. Es kam dann auch im Klartext immer die aktuellen Nachrichtenmeldungen für den Präsidenten, der kriegt permanent Bericht erstattet, was irgendwo abgeht. Da war so eine Meldung, Minor Hostage Problem in Texas, geringe Geiselproblematik, sodass sie zumindest schon mal wissen, da ist was und das könnte vielleicht schlimmer werden, aber halt noch nicht so schlimm. Das war halt alles problemlos mitzuhören.
Da gibt es ein Protokoll von, das ist sehr lustig zu lesen. Was ist auch gelesen, ne? Das sind ganz kleine Nachrichten untereinander. Gibt es da ein Link hin von eurer Seite?
Nee, aber ich müsste ihn noch irgendwo haben. Ich versuche das in den Ticker Feedback reinzunehmen.
Wie immer dann auf dem Chaosradio Server eine Menge Links zum Thema? Wahrscheinlich.
Na ja, über den Chaosradio Ticker schicken wir das raus. Wir sind auch sehr daran interessiert, dass Leute jetzt zugehört haben und die selber noch interessante Websites haben oder sonstige Informationen, die wir vielleicht auch falsch gesagt haben oder die Nachbesserungen bedürfen. Schickt uns das alles an chaos.orb.de und dann geht das in den Feedback rein und jeder der sich einen Ticker eingetragen hat, der kriegt das. Geht auch später auf den Webserver, aber ein Ticker kommt halt sofort.
Und allen Profis, die zuhören von diversen Firmen, denn, ähm, denke ich, kann man Serviceleistungen anbieten.
Ja, die Leute, die irgendwie bei solchen Mobilfunkbetreibern arbeiten, die sollen mal zu ihren Stützmanagern laufen und denen mal klar machen, wo das Problem ist. Die sollen mal zuhören.
Ich bin gespannt, was ihr da mit uns zu sehen habt.
Ist ja natürlich im Kern der Sache schon, aber jetzt wird's glaub ich noch ein bisschen lustig.
Eine interessante Sache.
Worüber lacht der Hacker?
Kommt ein Hacker zum Arzt? Ne ne, so ähnlich. Wer gerade ein Siemens S4 oder ein Siemens S6 Vorsicht zu liegen hat, der kann sich ja mal folgende Nummer aufschreiben.
S10 und S11 geht's glaub ich auch. Ja also beim Siemens S4 und beim Siemens S6 ist es halt ausprobiert. Der sollte sich folgende Nummer aufschreiben. Plus 1 2 0 2 2 2.
Ich denke du kannst sie auswendig.
3 1 3 4 oder so was?
Ich hab sie nicht richtig mitgeschrieben glaub ich.
Oder Tobias erzähl du erstmal, ich krieg die Nummer mal raus.
Na gut, jedenfalls muss man das eintragen unter der eigenen Rufnummer im Siemens und dann sieht man da ein lustiges Easter Egg, also ein verstecktes...
Ich hab die Nummer. Also es handelt sich in dem Schluss 1 2 0 2 2 2 4 3 1 2 1. Wenn man diese Rufnummer unter der eigenen Telefonnummer im Menü einträgt und dann Enter, also ok, so steht hier und drückt, dann erscheint ein kleiner Film auf dem Display des Telefons und die Namen der Entwickler der Telefonsoftware laufen durch. Die Nummer ist übrigens bezeichnenderweise die Rufnummer vom Weißen Haus.
Wie war das eigentlich mit Tetris bei Siemens?
Ja, im Siemens S1 waren Hidden Tetris eingebaut, das durch einen speziellen Code aktiviert werden konnte, dann konnte man das Telefon quer stellen und konnte auf der Tastatur Tetris spielen. Wurde später aus lizenzrechtlichen Gründen rausgenommen.
Schade. Jetzt gibt es doch irgendein Handy oder ein kleines Teleskop?
Genau, Nokia 6110 und 6130, da sind jetzt drei Spiele dabei. Bei Nokia gibt es auch einige Codes, zwar keine versteckten Filme oder sowas, aber Sachen um Softwarevision abzufragen und irgendwelche Einstellungen zu machen und so weiter. Das ist zum Beispiel der für die 81er Reihe, also 8110, 8148 und die 31er Reihe und die 38er Reihe, ist es die Sternraute 927-02689-raute. Und da kann man dann so Sachen abfragen, wie wann das Telefon das letzte Mal repariert wurde, wann es gekauft wurde. Also wenn es noch nicht repariert wurde, wird dann natürlich kein Datum eingetragen sein. Irgendwie kann ein mysteriösen Software-Download starten und solche Geschichten.
Was mir noch einfällt, wer nähere Untersuchungen zum Netzwerk anstellen will und ein Nokia, nein, stopp kein Nokia, ein AEG 9050 hat dieses etwas ältere, schlechte Handy ansonsten. Das hat aber eine sehr interessante Funktion. Man geht einfach in den Handy, Speicherplatz 99, also Speicher 99 und trägt dort den Namen Feldtest ein. Bestätigt mit Enter und in dem Augenblick hat man den kompletten Feldtest-Mode. Man kann sich Zellnummern anzeigen lassen, man kann sich Empfangsstärken anzeigen lassen, sozusagen das gesamte Engineering-Menü dieses Telefons ist danach aktiviert.
Ich glaube, du sagst nicht. Ich bin ja froh, dass es auch mal anderen Leuten passiert. Passiert hier ab und zu. Und da haben sie uns damals alle erzählt, digitale Technik kann nichts schiefgehen mit den CDs, die springen nicht mehr und so. Die springen? Ach, das ist bei der Nummer so. Na gut, dann vergesst was ich gesagt hab. Aber es klang, okay, es klang, aber das müsst ihr jetzt zugeben.
Um mich ein bisschen zu retten.
Aber es klingt, als ob eine CD Aussätze hat. Nur, wenn man nicht richtig zuhört. Ich wollte eigentlich sagen, dass CDs eben aber trotzdem manchmal springen, nur dass es nicht so schön klingt wie beim Vinyl damals. Obwohl bei diesem Song da gefällt es mir gut, aber für mich ist das...
Was ist das?
Was ist das? Was ist das?
Ja ein Update vielleicht noch zum Motorola Telefon und zwar folgende Information noch bei der neueren Software des Motorola StarTech. Ist jetzt von Motorola folgende Gemeinheit eingebaut worden. Man will halt die eigenen Akkus für viel Geld verkaufen, Lithium-Ionen Akku, ein originaler, kostet für den Motorola StarTech, also deutlich im dreistelligen Bereich. Man will sich gegen Fremdhersteller absichern, dass man halt nur Motorola Akkus kauft als Besitzer. Und deswegen hat Motorola jetzt eine Logik in den Chip eingebaut, die automatisch erkennt, ob der Akku von Motorola hergestellt wurde. Dieser Akku hat dann einen Zähler drin, der erzählt, wie oft der Akku entladen wird und geladen wird. Das Telefon akzeptiert nur noch Motorola Akkus. Es macht keine Batteriestandsanzeige mehr von Fremdakkus. Es lädt Fremdakkus nicht mehr auf, sprich man wird als Kunde an Motorola Akkus gebunden, kann sich nicht mehr günstig bei Fremdherstellern eindecken. Theoretisch wäre sogar möglich, dass es noch nicht erprobt, da diese Sache halt noch relativ jung ist, dass der Akku halt nach 250 Ladezyklen, die in ihm gespeichert sind, auf dem Chip einfach sagt, ich will jetzt nicht mehr, kaufe mich neue bei Motorola. Das wird noch zu erproben sein.
Ist das damit ein Wettbewerb, wenn ich ein Gerät herstelle, wo nur noch die von mir hergestellten Batterien benutzbar sind, also wenn sich das durchsetzt?
Sowas gibt es schon, das heißt Microsoft. Sehr erfolgreich.
Da musste ich gerade dran denken.
Das ist eine interessante Frage, ich bin kein Rechtsanwalt auf dem Gebiet, aber ich denke, da wird es demnächst Softwareupdates für die Telefone geben, eventuell Patches, die das wieder ausgleichen, bzw. müsste man versuchen, die Logik aus diesem Akku, der jetzt im Akku noch drin steckt, ins Telefon zu übernehmen und nur noch die Zellen auszulagern von dem Akku, sodass man dann eigene Akkus verwenden kann. Ist doch immerhin ein deutlicher Preisunterschied, ein fremd Akku kostet um die 20 Dollar. Der Lithium-Ionen Akku, der originale ist, in der Preisliste mit 160 Dollar.
Ja, ich frage mich nur, ob sowas wirklich vom Wettbewerbsrecht her funktioniert, aber das werden wir jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr rausfinden. Vielleicht, falls es irgendjemand da draußen gibt, der sowas weiß, da kann man uns eine E-Mail schreiben. Chaosradio nähert sich dem Ende, dann habe ich einen US. Herde Night Flight bei Fritz. Eine Sendung zum Thema Mobilfunk. Die Songs wurden live aufgelegt hier von Simplicity of Sound. Die ganze Zeit, alles was ihr gehört habt. Außer ganz am Anfang Kraftwerk, das wurde live aufgelegt von mir. Im Schacht versenkt sozusagen. Jetzt werden wir euch nochmal die Standards durchgeben für alle, die jetzt dursten nach mehr. Beziehungsweise die, die sich mal mit dem Chaos Computer Club in Verbindung setzen wollen. Und zwar nicht nur virtuell, sondern Gesicht zu Gesicht.
Genau, es gibt auf unserer Website immer viel Information. Ich kann das gar nicht mal alles irgendwie auch einmal wiedergeben. Was wir jetzt eingerichtet haben, sind Chaos Treffs. Es gab relativ viele Anfragen von Leuten aus verschiedensten Regionen in Deutschland, aber auch Österreich und der Schweiz, die in irgendeiner Form chaosnah aktiv werden wollen, die sie gerne treffen wollen, Stammtische bilden wollen, wo Leute, die sich kreativ mit Technologie beschäftigen, sich finden können und nicht irgendwo da sein müssen, wo wir im Wesentlichen aktiv sind. Also Hamburg, Berlin, Köln und Bielefeld und auch Menschglattbach, das sind so die Orte, wo R-Verkreise existieren, wo der CCC eine Niederlassung hat, wo wirklich auch Vereinsarbeit mitgeleistet wird. Und dann gibt es eben viele Chaos-Treffs, also von uns völlig losgelöste Treffpunkte. Und um das ein bisschen zu koordinieren, fassen wir diese ganzen Treffpunkte, Stammtische und so weiter auf unserer Homepage zusammen. Da kann man also mal reinschauen. Was noch erwähnenswert ist, dieser GSM-Hack, den haben wir halt mit unserem eigenen Chipkartenleser und Programmierer gemacht, dem UniProc, der jetzt einen Nachfolger erhält, den Serproc. Das ist eine abgewanderte Variante davon, die halt über eine serielle Schnittstelle verfügt, der einfacher zu bauen ist, billiger, richtig?
Na sie verfügt halt nur über die serielle Schnittstelle, sie läuft komplett an der seriellen, der UniProc davor hatte zusätzlich noch ein Verbindungskabel zur Parallel-Schnittstelle und das ist jetzt sozusagen weggefallen. Genau, das ist sozusagen handlicher und besser für unterwegs.
Und man kann mit jeder Maschine ran, die auch keinen Parallelport hat zum Beispiel. Und den wird's bei uns demnächst als Platine auch zu bestellen geben. Details werden dann demnächst auf dem Web-Server auftauchen. Ich schick das auch über einen Ticker raus. Wer also Interesse hat, private Sicherheitskopien von seinen Karten zu machen, falls er Angst hat, dass er mal eine verliert, der wäre zum Beispiel mit so einem Gerät ganz gut bezahlt.
Und am nächsten Monat, also wieder am letzten Mittwoch, das Monats Mai in diesem Fall, gibt's natürlich wieder Chaosradio. Thema wird dann sein in vier Wochen Internet für Fortgeschrittene. Das heißt, es wird ein bisschen ans Eingemachte gehen. Also vielleicht mal raus aus dem Browser und andere Software bzw. andere Internetdienste nutzen. Zum Beispiel Newsgroups, zum Beispiel IRC.
Ja, vor allem wollen wir zeigen, wie man eben effektiv mit dem Internet arbeiten kann. Also jetzt nur die Erwähnung und Aufzählung, dass es auch News gibt. Das hilft auch vielen Leuten nicht weiter, weil sie sich da eben verlieren. Wie finde ich halt eine Information gezielt? Wie benutze ich Suchmaschinen, sodass ich auch wirklich zu einem Rechercheergebnis komme und nicht nur im Netz brause oder surfe? Surfen macht ja alles ganz nett, um seine Zeit zu vertreiben. Man kann auch an die Fernseh gucken. Viel interessanter ist es eben für seine persönlichen Bedürfnisse, konkret an Informationen heranzukommen und wie man das macht, das wollen wir im nächsten Monat ein bisschen beleuchten.
Damit war es das hier im Chaosradio mit vier Jungs vom Chaos Computer Club mit Simplicity of Sound, bei denen wir uns bedanken für die wunderbare Musik. Und wir sind ausnahmsweise in time. Völlig erstaunlich. Und waren relativ relaxt, finde ich, die drei Stunden. Mit einem Lächeln gehen wir nach Hause und ihr schlaft hoffentlich mit einem Lächeln ein, falls ihr nicht noch arbeiten müsst.
Drei Minuten nach eins.